the mainstream media
politico
finally says
the hunter biden laptop story is
confirmed are reporters publishing a
book where they actually corroborated
emails with witnesses
that the deals between the bidens and
china and ukraine and 10 held by h for
the big guy
yeah apparently it's all real and you
know what it doesn't feel like news
because uh the we know
but at least now we're finally getting
acknowledgement and that's pretty big
considering the
ineptitude of the blind administration
and the chaos that we're witnessing the
democratic agenda is on the verge of
failing republicans are threatening to
hold up the budget bill the squad is
getting the iron dome budgeting pulled
from israel now israel's panicking the
borders in shambles biden has been
unable to deal with anything and now the
media is coming out like oh that hundred
buying stuff it's real i gotta wonder at
what point do they 25th amendment joe
biden so we've got that talk about we
got a bunch of other stories talk about
a lot of weird stories you know there's
that whipping scandal with the horses in
texas and it's just like not true we've
got weird stories about smugglers
smuggling in kfc i think it was to
auckland apparently it's a south park
episode
too much of south park has come true you
guys so we're hanging out with a couple
we got daniel turner hanging out
thank you always good to be back you
want to introduce yourself yeah daniel
turner uh power of the future daniel
turner ptf on twitter um and it is
always fun to be here with you fine
folks so thanks for the invite
absolutely and we got chris carr hanging
out yes sir that's right thanks for
having me executive editor of the
awesome rockstar journalist at
timcast.com uh happy to be back it's
always a pleasure absolutely and i'll
see you again as well danny i just see
you the nicest guy in the history of
mankind
i i met you last time and i was like i
feel like i made a new best friend i
felt the same way that's what i went
home and told my wife i was just like
daniel and us we're going to hang out
yeah yeah it's a good time good time
chris has also been making drinks i
don't know if that's if everyone knows
yet but he's uh quite a mixologist over
there yeah yeah we got a nice little
menu put together yeah people are loving
it hi i'm ian crossan by the way the the
what is you you made like the republican
we got the republican real quick what is
the republican the republican is
essentially just uh i think it's like a
cosmo it's like an elevated cosmo
basically but uh but it's red and what's
the democrat the democrat is a shot of
milort
room room temperature
yeah yeah just
for those who don't know what is it's a
chicago novelty liqueur that apparently
people in chicago i've never had it but
people in chicago always tell people not
from chicago to try it because it's kind
of a prank on them
and the joke is that it's grown from the
grass on the side of interstate 55. i'm
not trying to disparage my lord we
bought some we're fans we love it and we
have na we have made a drink of a room
temperature shot of melor did you spin
up the independent yet
uh not yet that will not matter oh no
well what we do have is a centrist which
is a it's a it's a martini that's like
half vodka half gin just in case you
can't decide yeah yeah
and we're and we're focusing on
mocktails healthy ones healthy drinks
we've got we got one in the bank
called the sweetheart oh it's delicious
it's really good and it's made with
biotrusts yeah we're not we're not
promoting it but they have this one
thing that we we made it it's like it's
a it's lemon juice it's this bio trust
reds it's so good it's like strawberry
and beets i think they're in there oh
yeah yeah we are not promoting them
right now we will promote them you know
i think in a few days or whatever but
we're just pointing out like we made a
really awesome drink so uh yeah we got
lydia i have really big news for
everyone i realized tonight when i
checked my twitter and i checked sour
patch kids twitter that i have surpassed
sour patch kids and followers so this is
like my goal in life i've reached a peak
i don't know what to do now i got
nothing my next goal is a million i
guess that's ian said so yeah
someone already super chatted us milort
is actually amazing omg and all kinds of
i don't know i haven't tried it they're
lying they're like when you so when when
you look it up on google it actually
says it's a bitter astringent novelty
drink and i'm like
i don't drink alcohol but it's gross
that's why we have the fancy healthy
drinks but my friends let's get into
this news before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member and
you'll get access access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim cast
irl podcast as well as a whole bunch of
new content that is in the works you'll
get an ad free experience and let me
just point out tonight around 11 we will
put up our members only segment after
this show so we basically do an extended
show where we cuss and we're swearing
and we're banging on the tables and
flipping stuff over and we actually have
if you missed it the alex jones members
only segment we went for like an hour
and a half
because i don't know if you saw that
episode last night but i have no ability
whatsoever to control a conversation
when alex jones is here but i asked phil
labonte from all that remains like phil
i'm going to need someone who's strong
and capable
who can control a conversation who can
take charge in a room and he's like you
got it and then when alex went off phil
starts laughing yes and i'm like phil
help me
so it's fun check it out and don't
forget to like this video subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's talk about the big
political news that in my opinion
let me just let me just we'll start over
here it is fox news politico
confirmation of hunter biden laptop
materials prompts criticism of earlier
suppression of story twitter blocked
sharing of new york post story on laptop
last year so the new york post told the
truth hunter biden is he's a crackhead
correct he's a crackhead there's there's
photos and videos of him with like
women of the night he'll repute yes
no i don't know i don't know if ill
repute is is is fair and acceptable to
our libertarian audience who think you
know sex work is acceptable the oldest
on earth there you go that's why i say
women of the night that's not offensive
is it ladies and gentlemen negative i'm
i'm trying to be a libertarian although
you know personally not a fan but uh you
got to be careful because
i don't know that one's actually tough
we should have a conversation about that
maybe when we're not doing family we
could even have a prostitute on some day
to give their personal experience of the
night a woman of the night so anyway
look hunter biden is is is a is a mess
but i don't i don't care you know what i
mean like sure he's a guy he does a
thing a lot of people have problems i'm
not here to revel in a man's problems
the problem i have is it's not criticism
of an earlier suppression of the story
it's criticism of
a democrat democratic operatives working
in media
working at big tech suppressing news
that would have substantia would have
hurt joe biden in the election to a
great degree not because hunter biden
does drugs but because the emails showed
that they were holding 10 that 10 will
be held by h for the big guy that there
were nefarious deals going on and we
don't want a president going into office
who has nefarious deals now back when
trump was running they're like donald
trump as a secret server communicating
with russia
lies
so when their criticism was we don't
want a president entering office who has
these ties to foreign interests and is
beholden to them in these debts i'm like
all right you know i can accept that to
a certain degree now it's one thing if
you're a businessman like trump and you
have buildings with mortgages all over
the world
that's like saying we don't want someone
who runs international business to be
president for the sake that they just
because they run international business
now to that extent i will say
true
in some degree for joe biden but when
joe biden flies to ukraine and says
fire the prosecutor
that or you're not getting your billion
dollar in loans joe biden has no right
to leverage the united states providing
aid to ukraine in a conflict with russia
or or potentially there's a con this
conflict between russia and ukraine
threatening them you know we're going to
pull out unless you fire this prosecutor
and as matt taibbi reported the
prosecutor was investigating barisma
where his son was on the board that is
dramatically different from trump having
debt in buildings
so this story gets suppressed what do we
get
i think you know you look at the rest
music study rasmussen did a study final
i think it was like what seven to ten
percent of people yeah nine percent nine
percent when asked
if you knew about the hunter biden stuff
would you have voted for by no
so that would have been dramatically
different now here we are what's been
happening economy inflation's through
the roof border crisis afghanistan
crisis domestic agendas failing dem the
squad members are i mean i'm already at
five squad members are ripping the
democratic party to shreds which they've
been doing for some time but now they're
pulling funding for the iron dome
wow is the bite administration
completely
unfit now here's my favorite part there
was a poll back in august
most americans think joe biden is unfit
to be president do you know what the
poll today is most uh the uh 48 so it's
not the majority because it's 48 think
he's not even mentally stable well
that's where we are
when when the media manipulates and lies
on news we knew to be true that we had
already confirmed i was independently
confirmed by people looking at the
emails corroborating it and they
suppress this this is why you end up
with a cult that believes insane things
like the economy is good and regular
people of different political
persuasions like everyone here probably
has you know different political world
views but we can recognize the truth
when we see it
i think what annoys me the most about
this story is the media always is is
pulling their weight in a certain favor
right i mean we have innumerable
examples of that in the trump
administration and going back to as long
as i've been following politics what
bothers me the most about this
particular episode is i cannot find
that i could be wrong but i can't find
in my my memory whole
one other time that twitter actually
suspended technologically the ability to
share the story they have labeled things
as inaccurate facebook of always puts
their stamps on it but the fact that if
you wanted to retweet the story you were
not allowed to
is a whole
new level of crackdown that we never saw
before but you couldn't even send it in
a private message right yes didn't they
crack down on that too i mean that's
privately that is unbelievable they
suspended one of the oldest newspapers
in this country alexander hamilton 1799.
and we all knew
very early on the story was true because
of independent corroboration statements
from people like tony bobulens you came
out and said yes i'm on those email
chains yes those emails are real and
we're like okay so i'm looking at this
like it's not news we knew it was real
what's the revelation but they suspended
a newspaper and the crazy thing is
it's taken
it's how many months it's been almost a
year
and now they're like oh new york post
was telling the truth the whole time and
that's where you have to go to twitter
the ceo and and they bring him before
congress all the time and they never ask
him hard questions they never really ask
the questions they should but the
question should be here are an example
of 10 other stories that you could
consider as inflammatory as shocking as
controversial you never suspect that
were also false you never suspended any
of them so twitter walk me through i get
it private platform they can do whatever
they want is the argument walk me
through the criteria that for this story
someone made the decision to say this is
why we have to suspend it as opposed to
and you've dealt with this in your own
personal life one person says all these
things they're totally fine you say this
and it's like
suspended well what was the criteria and
it seems to be well i just don't like
that person it feels kind of like being
in a band that was a one-hit wonder and
being like you know i had this big song
back in the 80s because because a few
years ago i went to the joe rogan
podcast and i was talking to jack dorsey
and it's like one
people bring this up all the time so
that's the you know kind of the point
i'm making but i showed them a tweet
from antifa where they were like
everyone go to this place at this time
to commit violence and i was like how
has this tweet been up for months and
the replies to it are getting banned so
clearly someone at twitter sees this
bans replies but lets that one stay i'm
like are you guys feds because the only
reason i can understand that you would
keep that up is it's bait yeah from the
feds makes sense and they're like we we
didn't know about it oh oh geez oh no
i'm like nah okay look
i'm i'm i'm done playing these games
some trump supporter guy says hashtag
learn to code it was you know what it
was it was the editor-in-chief of the
daily caller i think yeah jeffrey
ingersoll
was he didn't tweet anybody he tweeted
the hashtag he tweeted about learn to
code and they suspended him that that
that i got my details right absolutely
yeah i remember that was hysterical but
you can say it about coal miners that's
what i john jumped on that because
that's the response that that they say
all the time about people in the energy
industry oh you got to learn to code
like that it has been used as a learner
skill that you need in the 21st century
but you can't say that to what was what
was it um gawkers right it was about was
it when gawker was fired or one of those
but it was one of those it was one of
those publications that went down and
that's what that was pretty funny
i hear you on the congress stuff but i
really don't think there's anything you
can do
bringing these people before congress i
think they are duplicitous
i think they are liars i think they keep
calling in jack dorsey who's a
spokesperson figurehead who doesn't
actually do anything with the company
because jack tweeted he he tweeted the
the anatomy of the state by rothbard and
everyone like was like whoa because he
clearly is not
don't you know it is a weird thing from
a tweet considering he provides cover
for the machine
but i don't think he's actually running
the show they keep bringing these people
before congress and saying you know you
did this and they're like oh i'll get
back to you i don't know it's nothing
happens nothing nothing changes
i think this country's imploded already
you know i mentioned it the day before
i've mentioned on my other show
and you take a look at the fact that
they've brought how many times have they
been pulled before congress over this
stuff five i don't know
there's no way there's going to be any
meaningful legislation to deal with the
suppression of our speech on these
platforms and the left like say but my
private platform and i'm like it's it's
it's a it's an inane argument okay they
have conquered the commons plus we're
locked down in a lot of places people
can't go out so this is how we're
communicating
at a certain point when they control too
much we have anti-trust laws we or we
come in and we regulate we do these
things we always do it we normally do it
because we don't want companies usurping
the power of the citizenry and the
people and suppressing the rights of the
working class
none of that's going to happen because
there's no way that republicans and
democrats will agree
even when we had republicans in 2016-18
they were too stupid to realize what was
happening and now they're all getting
banned and they're all but those were
mostly like neocons you know paul ryan
stuff like that
now what we're seeing is while the
republicans can't get anything done
democrats are just cheating they're
trying to put immigration reform in a
spending bill
joe biden is just ruling by decrees
rubber stamping legislation as executive
order and then it just it just happens
so i i all i see is
i was i was reading about um decline of
civilizations before
and there's a period at which
it's been a while but i can't get into
specifics where like you'll start to see
autocratic rule because
it becomes so dysfunctional that the
only way to actually move forward is for
a sovereign to decree and say we have to
do this now otherwise we're doing
nothing so they force things to happen
and that just exacerbates the
stabilization
there are two components of this story
there's the
censorship which is extremely
frustrating says you know suppression of
free speech
um what it did to the election etc but
then there's the actual
story itself which is how corrupt is
this family i mean
obviously they've got an awful lot of of
skeletons in their closet and when
you've got a sitting vice president who
negotiated uh trade deals and planned
for his future and every president and
vice president plans for their future
right i mean they all know it's not
going to last forever but he was using
clearly the power of government to build
himself a a very profitable very
lucrative heck you saw it in his tax
returns right his last year as vice
president his net wealth was 400 and
some thousand dollars that year and then
here after it was 17 point something
million and you're like wow that's a
really great profit margin good year for
him a very good year and so but there's
that level of of corruption that you say
well what were the trade deals that you
were negotiating and and again the 10
for the big guy
and they seem to be with pretty awful
people right there it's with china it's
with ukraine it's with and and you know
i hate to rag on hunter biden um
well actually i don't because he's he's
a deplorable uh
vile human being when your brother dies
of cancer and within the year you are
sleeping with his wife you're leaving
your own wife and your children to sleep
with your dead brother's wife and then
while you're sleeping with your former
sister-in-law making your
cousins now step children you're
sleeping with her sister simultaneously
and in top of the sister you impregnate
a stripper in alabama
you are just you are a scumbag i'm sorry
there's no other way around that like
like and and i'm sorry joe biden must
hate that he looks at hunter because it
reminds him the good son died and that's
gotta eat at him because you are truly a
vile vile human being to do that to your
kids imagine his poor kids and they show
the kids all the time the grandkids joe
biden's grandkids my dad was dead and
this dirtbag is sleeping with my what a
disgusting family they're like the
kennedys without the money or the class
wow well i do want well two things first
of all you did get me a little worked up
talking about the lira details of his
love life that was yeah it was pretty
steamy uh second of all i would like to
defend him because this man is an artist
okay this man is an artist and where
would we be if it weren't for vile
deplorable human beings who create
quality art i mean he's stretching 75k
yeah yeah so he's an artist that's what
happens that's what artists do they live
they live wild libertine lives this is
why i said i love christmas
they cut deals with china and they kick
back you know 10 to the big guy while
he's in office and uh and no one has to
know who bought the art
yes
that's totally cool sounds like money
laundry
let me let me look i love pulling up the
story because it's important for for
anybody who's like how do i tell my
friends and family about this stuff i
think there's a lot of people who are in
the cult who are who are
i don't want to say too far gone but
very difficult to reach and it's and
it's hard to get to them but at the very
least you can show them an article this
from politico
biden inc that big right of center
publication politico right that huge
over his decades in office middle class
joe's family fortunes have closely
tracked his political career from august
of 2019 and i think they actually have
uh they have like a graphic look at this
they show when joe budden enters the
senate and then james biden
operates seasons change nightclub with
help from unusually generous bank loans
unusually in 87 he launched his first
presidential campaign in his mi uh so
about eight years later his brother uh
james and sarah biden's lion hall group
hired to push washington agenda of
tobacco trial lawyers from mississippi
so uh the most important one in my
opinion is let me let me try and find i
think it's 2011.
let me see if i can um
okay here we go
in
where's joe biden joe biden sworn in as
vip to those nine paradigms connections
to ponzi scheme or alan stanford and the
fraudulent ponte negra fund come to
light james biden under binding began to
unwind to unwind paradigm
james biden joins hillstone
international in june of 2011 hillstone
international lands a 1.5 billion
contract to build housing in iraq so joe
biden becomes vice president joe biden
is put in charge of the iraq operation
his brother gets contracts for building
in in iraq you know you look at this map
put together by politico tracking his
family's fortunes around him
and
it's just come on it's just so obvious i
mean if the government if not the
government if cnn was able to track down
through facebook that that
old woman who shared a meme about
president trump and knocked on her door
to ask her about it you're going to tell
me the government can put in some system
to say if chris becomes president
chris's sister can't get a 1.5 billion
dollar contract like all these things
were just like oh my gosh we had there
was no safeguards for any of this i mean
it's just it's mind-boggling the level
of grift and corruption and scumbaggery
it's just
it breaks your heart because it makes
you think there's no one left but but
the to the if you were to argue the side
of the people the people on the other
side of the aisle the people that are
really hard to reach they're just going
to say yeah that's politics that's
politics yeah that's just how it goes
what's the big deal so joe made some
money i mean that's just that's how the
system works they all do it yeah they
all do it they'll do it look at trump
yeah they'll tell you yeah
that's exactly right i'll cite some
stories about trump that are not the
same as i mentioned or or fake yeah and
this the story from joe biden from 2019
it's not like he was running for office
and there was a smear piece against him
now i'm not gonna i'm not gonna pretend
trump's a saint but there's a big
difference between being some crazy real
estate mogul who's got a bunch of
buildings around the world and you have
debts on them like i think it's funny
when the story came out where they're
like trump was 500 million in debt on
his properties and people were like whoa
and i'm like yeah okay
those are his liabilities what are his
assets
and then trump came out and he was like
yes i have mortgages on buildings like
everybody else and the buildings are
worth a billion um
it just lies
manipulation yeah and and just the biden
the unraveling of their level of
corruption i think deserved to come to a
head before the election and clearly did
not um but this is this is standard
behavior for the media where they either
exacerbate stories that they think are
are interesting or fascinating or a
narrative you could look to we're going
to talk about miss potato later on right
there's a narrative they like to push of
missing women there's a narrative about
racism they like to push but then you
have another story you know case in
point there was a terrible school
shooting three or four days ago and i
forget where it was
news
no coverage because people looked at the
narrative and they were like eh it
doesn't help the cause well nothing i
would like to say that we did cover that
at tim castner good yes as it should we
did kind of you should have because it
is newsworthy but this is where you know
i think what bothers me about the media
um
and just just their their level of
disgusting behavior because they push
their narrative is
one of the very first things that
happened when trump was sworn into
office
um and i've followed media bias for a
while but this one i thought set the
tone for his administration uh january
20th 2017 it was 5 30 in the afternoon
hours after and it was uh zeke miller on
behalf of the white house press pool who
tweeted uh president trump has removed
the martin luther king bus from the oval
office that's right and sean spicer saw
the tweet in real time and was like dude
it's right there
but it didn't matter the damage was done
and he could have as a good member of
the press said hey sean i gotta ask
before i tweet this did you remove the
mlk bust and spicer would have said no
it's right there but he didn't verify
because he won the damn narrative and
that's what they do
all the time and you just have to see
that those things explode 500 000
retweets one million likes but then the
retraction you know it's not journalism
it's a gossip it is it is that's it like
i mean
all that and they're not now they're
defunct thank god but they don't know
they're back but they will they're back
as in and nbc and and politico and i
don't know gawker itself a new version
has re-emerged is it still called gawker
yes it is oh gosh but it really started
with yellow journalism like there's been
a long tried history of like really i
mean just biased reporting yeah so it's
been around for a long time and it's
just gotten worse yeah so there's money
to be made you know the crazy thing is
we can see it now and we're shocked by
it but imagine the stories you would
have read in the paper in the 90s the
80s 90s 2000s before we had a strong
internet
culture that was challenging and fact
checking yeah people just believe that
look at the nbmc's man yeah look at the
nbc news uh during the the the trayvon
martin case right remember they edited
the audio uh of of um
zimmerman and it was like and he said he
looks like blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah black and they just clipped it
he looks like he's black and they were
like wow he said something like he said
that he looks like he's up to no good he
looks black yeah and then it turns out
he said he looks like he's up to no good
and then says is he white is he mexican
or he goes he's black yeah
they just took all that out do you
remember when the on september 11th when
they said they found one of the guys
passports one of the hijackers passports
on the ground outside the wreckage oh
yeah like it fell out of the airplane
and landed on the ground i don't
remember that you know that was media
that's insane holy cow the one thing
that survived amongst the rubble is his
password yeah they're like we got him we
know who's laid on top well that's
that's the official story yeah isn't
that what the heck like a passport fell
out of an airplane what are they talking
about
you know
jet fuel doesn't melt passports
apparently not i don't i don't know why
ian went there with the story
free internet news it's like that was
like the end of the pre-internet news
era and then the math weapons of mass
destructions thing and
now we kind of have an ability to
fact-check stuff on our own but uh
before like the first war in iraq i
wonder how much was going on there that
we don't i got it i got it i got a
really good example for you guys you
ready for this one
we have the story from august 19th 2021
oh it is from cnn
from chris saliza ah the great
crystallization republicans treat
okay republicans keep trying to make
biden's mental capacity an issue oh no
and then that he goes on to mention
people calling him out you know saying
that his mental capacity is an issue and
it's a republican game and blah blah
blah i'm not going to read this right
you know why
because i can just pull up first from a
day later
most voters deemed but an unfit to be
president poll shows okay okay well
that's not
saying mental capacity like chrysalis
was challenging but it does show that
most voters think he's not capable of
being president
now we have this story
less than half of americans say brennan
is mentally stable enough to serve as
president chris
it's not republicans trying to make it
an issue yeah it's people being polled
saying his brain don't work it's an
issue it's an issue it's an issue
yeah um i i'm feeling pretty
black-pilled on this yeah because
earlier today
i'm looking at all this news and i see
this story less than half of americans
say button is meant is is mentally
stable enough to serve as president
and i was like
yeah we know that and then i'm thinking
to myself so i did a segment on this
where i was like not as much about the
fact that biden can't
function properly and everything's
collapsing and the country's basically
on fire and i was just like
i know the border screwed up i know the
economy screwed up i know our foreign
policy is screwed up i know the
president has no idea what's going on
and i know his cabinet's in shambles and
they're confused jen sackey is muttering
and stuttering and summoning and
stammering and circling back and then
i'm like what am i even gonna say about
this yeah and then i was like actually
if that's where we're at as a country
we are
seriously screwed
well i i i believe myself we are bleeped
yeah okay because
we're at a point now where it is
uninteresting to people to hear that the
president of the united states
is viewed as mentally unfit
mentally
not not mentally stable enough
that that we're seeing the catastrophe
and the crisis across the country and
we've normalized to it to the point
where it is not surprising to hear
americans don't see the president as
stable mentally stable i i have a
slightly different theory and i wonder i
was developing this idea while we were
talking about the hunter biden story so
the laptop now is officially correct
everyone agrees the new york post of
course is shocked this is the case
um but i think i wonder if the hunter
biden thing is a segway to being like oh
my gosh biden is incredibly corrupt not
only do most people think he's unfit to
be president like mentally unstable they
also think he's super corrupt maybe we
should just 25th amendment him out of
here so maybe maybe kamala harris's team
made this story get to politico to say
let's just start you know doing the
damage i don't know right
yeah that's that's a great that's a
great theory you mentioned jen sackey
today and and and just again
the spinning of lies what we need is we
need like your parents remember when you
would get caught like either drunk or
late or whatever as a kid and you tried
to tell your mom a story and she was
like
no like tell me what the hell actually
happened like she wasn't buying it
ginsaki today when peter ducey asked so
you are asking europeans to show their
covet passport but if you cross the
border illegally you don't have to show
your covet passport and she said well
yes unlike the europeans the illegals
are not planning to stay a long time
and that was the end of the question and
no one in the room was the mom to be
like wait wait wait wait wait wait hold
up you think the europeans are staying a
long time and the illegals are temporary
like they're not here for travel
like
what you just said is a complete 180
degree lie they just like oh genseki
said this and they write it down and
they and they tweet it and that's it and
they we need an adult to finally say
time out time out jen that was just a
lie we want to you want to take that
over again we just accept
lies i mean we would need a michael
malus press secretary yes yeah
caucus libertarian dave smith i don't
even care if this whole country becomes
communist in 20 years if i can see
michael malus's press secretary for one
day
i will die happy that's that's all i
want to say there's one guy in the
diplomatic press corps when i used to
work at the state department in the bush
administration long long time ago and
he's still there matt lee and he is by
far the senior most foreign policy
journalist
and he used to make our lives miserable
because i worked in the press office
and he he was ruthless and he's the only
one but again it doesn't get as much
attention because it's the foreign
policy beat but but he will just take
him to ask and say no no no hang on you
just said this
you said this yesterday that doesn't
make any like if you ever watch his
exchange
he does not buy bs that's really the
difference between an investigative
journalist and a reporter a reporter is
going to say you lie to him and i'm just
going to report on the law or the white
house press pool where they're all just
like oh gen sec you said this and they
type it down we need more investigated
journalists in there but they don't
really get invited right it's like an
invite-only thing no it's it's it's
press work it's the white house
reporters they're they're just there to
ask questions and report what's said
they're not investigating but we
definitely need
you know you know we need someone to
challenge it but i'll say this
nobody cares you know why
because when we look at stories about
you know like the cnn the republicans
are trying to make it an issue that
biden's not mentally republicans pounce
and i'm like it's i'm not it's not
republicans um it's independent voters
overwhelmingly disapprove of joe biden
yeah but everything you know i love it
when when i did the russell brand
podcast and was talking about civil war
and i just went to town as fast as i
could on all the different points about
like street fighting january uh six all
that stuff and psychological warfare
fifth generational warfare and the
comments were like tim poole is a
leftist you know he says this about
trump tim poole is a right winger he
says this about biden and i'm just like
these people don't seem to realize that
independent voters exist yeah so they
come out and they're like it's just
republicans and i'm like
you know it was funny there was this
research that the researcher who did
this thing on youtube uh years ago where
he was tracking the political uh
persuasions of youtube recommendations
and he was doing it because of this idea
of the rabbit hole that they kept
pushing and so he had uh i think he
basically had four categories
left center right and exclusively
critical of left and he initially put
people like me and dave rubin in the
category of exclusively critical of left
and so i talked to him and i pointed out
like
why is that the case when i do express
my opinions that are i think the real
issue was we were taught we were
complaining about democrats
but our opinions were not right-wing
that was the only issue so if i said
something like hey a green new deal that
actually rebuilds infrastructure is a
good thing the democrats are pushing
some weird socialist garbage about
universal college that's not a green new
deal he's like you're just criticizing
the left i'm like i'm literally
supporting a leftist policy but either
the left was in favor of critical race
theory
centrists were like mixed on it and the
right opposed it so if you opposed
critical race theory you were just
called a critical of left i'm like that
that that's how people even researchers
view what's happening right now and i'm
like isn't it perhaps you're a centrist
then or heterodox or something or
politically homeless
no
politics only flows in one direction if
a right-wing dude stands next to a
left-wing dude the left-wing dude is
called right wing if a right-wing dude
is hanging out with antifa and they're
all waving anti-flags and he's got his
arms around their you know their
shoulders with his thumbs up they will
say they're actually secret right
wingers yeah
yeah when i get into conversations with
this with people one of my favorite
things to say is okay so you hear about
the right wing a lot the right wing is
obviously a problem in your view right
oh yeah definitely definitely the news
is always reporting it there's a there
you know far right-wing extremists i'm
just like so is there a is there a far
left
oh no there's not a fart left
they don't they don't they just can't
see it they refuse to see it it's
willful blindness yeah and legislatively
they know that because that's why they
have to like you mentioned the green new
deal with all this leftist
garbage in it
and i also oppose the green new deal um
but they have to sneak that leftist
garbage in it because if it stood on its
own they know they wouldn't have a vote
for it look you mentioned the beginning
of the show you mentioned the
immigration bill why are they trying to
tag it into a spending bill because they
know they can't pass an immigration but
the immigration bill they want so they
have to squeeze it into and that's just
what our congress does now we don't
write if we could have a vote on this
water bottle where everyone yay or nay
water bottle congress would work but
instead it's like well we can't do that
because we don't want to i don't want to
go on record about the water bottle
right so we take
everything and throw it on a fourth
house that's where we are 4 000 page 3.5
trillion dollars we will vote on it on
christmas eve at nine o'clock at night
and that's what we do because all of
these things if they stood on their own
i don't want to get judged on that so we
throw them all in this crap sandwich and
we call it like the for the children of
tomorrow holding hands across america
and then like if you don't vote for this
chris you hate the troops and they're
like and you hate america and it's like
i just want to vote on the water bottle
but hold on so why doesn't rand paul or
thomas massey just slide stuff in i'll
tell you this when they did the omnibus
spending bill remember that 5 000
something pages 12 million dollars for
pakistani gender studies programs i
don't know about any of you listening
but i don't care from the left or the
right we can all agree that spending 12
million on gender study programs in
america is better than giving it to
pakistan at least you'd create american
jobs actually i don't know if i agree
with that necessarily we don't want
weird but i guess
but why are we giving our money away for
ridiculous things like this more
importantly when i see that i'm like
rand paul yeah if you're listening
can you just write something very simple
saying and we abolish the federal
reserve yeah and just slide it in there
because nobody read it
he knows nobody right everybody votes on
it and they're like yay and then all of
a sudden they're like did we just
abolish the federal reserve
so why doesn't he do that i don't know
because they they i think because they
see the process as an honorable
righteous constitutionally mandated and
this is how we do it so we don't violate
the rules when they have power they
violate the rules left and right but
when we get power we don't play by their
rules now there's a growing movement on
the right i would say it's led by a guy
named jesse kelly there is a growing
movement of the right that says when we
get power we will double down on that
because that is now that what he is
calling the new right when we get power
look they're trying to not abolish the
filibuster and in people like joe
manchin are trying no and kristen cinema
senator from arizona we're not going to
abolish the filibuster it's part of our
history
if we get patent if the right gets power
in 2022 absolutely abolish the
filibuster and torture these people yeah
change all of the rules and take all of
the power and crush your enemies that
there i don't agree with that i'm just
saying that's what the new right right
they're scared because i think it was
harry reid who changed the rules yeah
and so they said you will rule the day
and they did they did and look they look
what they got they got gorsuch they got
uh um the other guy and and and when the
third one
it was my memory they got gorsuch and
they got kavanaugh and they got um
uh uh amy coney back yeah yes yeah did
you did you see this story check this
out from the guardian yeah to protect
the supreme court's legitimacy a
conservative justice should step down
if presidents do not get to replace
justices in election year then coney
barrett's confirmation is illegitimate
there you go presidents do then
gorsuchus is illegitimate you can't have
it both ways these they they they
operate on lies the only way lawrence
douglas is able to convince people of
this stuff is by omitting key
information notably that it is not about
replacing a just an election year
mitch mcconnell was specifically talking
about if you do not control the senate
they will not confirm your appointee and
we would be wasting our time by having
everyone sit around and then vote no
republicans are not going to approve
garland for you it was garland right
right for obama so they were so he was
like you don't have the senate you do
not have the votes for confirmation the
country is not unified when it came to
amy coney barrett and gorsuch it was or
cody specifically is that they had the
presidency and the senate so they were
able to do it yeah it's that simple
they operate on lies
they use false arguments and that's how
they maintain control and don't forget
when when when mcconnell first said that
according to the new york times hillary
clinton had a 97 chance of winning
hillary clinton although she would
probably deny this hillary clinton
probably when that happened was like
i agree with that because she was
convinced with 97 chance she was going
to win and she wanted to appoint her own
justice to the supreme court she
probably secretly and her team were like
that's awesome yeah let's let's hold the
merrick garland when we get to pick
because we're going to win so much so
they had ordered fireworks right she was
going to win
i remember i remember that election yeah
it's a day to remember a lot of people
are sharing um a new report that cern
large hadron collider is going to be
firing up again and i don't know if you
all know this but didn't didn't they
fire up on 2016 smashing particles
together or whatever when they found the
higgs boson no i don't know but the the
joke conspiracy is that they
accidentally warped us into an alternate
reality or something somehow donald
trump became president and all that
stuff and uh and now they're doing it
again and who knows what's gonna happen
but uh this is this is the state of the
country where the democrats uh the
establishment media are duplicitous they
manipulate they deceive they use fake
arguments and i'm no fan of the
republican party i think they do nothing
you literally have republicans
here's what happens
democrats are like we would like to
strip the rights away from law-abiding
citizens in this country and republicans
go no wait don't and they say well you
guys are at don't we're at strip their
rights how about we strip half of their
rights and republicans go okay good
competition for them yeah yeah yeah this
is
so i i don't know about you know you
were just mentioning that
when about abolishing the filibuster
that when republicans get in do it
abolish filibuster and then just trample
over democrats i don't want to see that
happen i'm saying that's what people are
saying right yeah but yeah so i i think
there's obviously people saying let's do
let's go nuclear i think that
contributes to the gradual decline of
the us system of governance and the
reason we're seeing democrats like joe
biden bypass the legislature and supreme
court and def in violation of our norms
and law is because they're tired they
want to get things done they want to do
things they can't
this country used to move slowly
you used to have to like ride on
horseback to go to dc to cast a vote and
and policy moved slowly now they're like
it must be done now yeah okay here's
what i want to see lauren bobert
would you please
keep consistently filing bills to repeal
the nfa
can we get marjorie taylor green as well
thomas massey rand paul all you guys
repeal the nfa give me a good reason why
they would why not seriously why not
national firearms act no no get rid of
it we have the right to keep and bear
arms i'm not saying that we would
legitimately repeal the nfa but at the
very least the terms of the argument
should not be no wait don't yeah it
should literally be like okay democrats
you're at gun control we're at complete
deregulation of all gun laws in the
country how about we agree upon will
only ban fully auto
how about we we about we we're going to
repeal the nfa and then you could start
arguing from our position on gun rights
they don't do that republicans never do
this no they they buy into the common
sense gun rules right and that's just
what you do you just rephrase it as
common sense gun protection common sense
gun restrictions and
now we've we've ex we've ceded to the
argument that these are common sense as
opposed to saying this isn't common
sense this is unconstitutional but it's
not even i don't mean to make it about a
gun rights thing and be like guns i'm
not paying the table i'm saying quite
literally when the democrats go
universal healthcare the republicans
don't go deregulation of government
healthcare they go no wait don't yeah
and then the democrats say okay you're
at stop and we're at government
healthcare how about we meet halfway and
do you know public option yeah which is
most of the time what what happens and
then they get most of what they wanted
anyway
i would like to go back the democrats
tell people it's inverted yeah that
we're helpless the republicans are
stopping so much more i would just like
to go back to single-issue votes like
the water bottle i can't understand why
we can't get people in congress who will
say this is the bill and it's a page and
a half and here's how much it costs and
it goes through the appropriate
committee and it goes through markup and
it makes it to instead we get these
monster monster monster bills we don't
even do the appropriation process right
right we don't and that's why people
like
joe biden's brother get 1.5 trillion
dollar contracts because it's
it's rolled up into the the defense
reauthorization act and and
no one knows where it is what's the
appropriation process the way it should
work is that if it depends upon what the
issue is say it's transportation right
uh we want to build a bridge between
these two states federal government has
to get in job it has to go through the
transportation subcommittee the
department of transportation has to make
their proposal transportation
subcommittee works it up appropriation
says how much do we have in the treasury
and then they those two then together
bring it to the floor for the larger
vote and then you got to whip the votes
and say you're going to vote for my
bridge and i'll vote for your bridge but
if you vote for my bridge and and then
the senate actually works but what's
happening now how is that different we
are just bypassing all that you know
what's happening the the the
transportation committee will have a
markup on racism and the in the
transportation department and they'll
talk about the inherent racism of of of
the taxi cabs and they'll say if you
inherit racism
buddha judge in his confirmation talked
about how you we must acknowledge as a
country that most of our infrastructure
was built on racism and they say if you
don't vote for my bill you hate the
troops you're racist
all that stuff
so then they'll take your bridge and
they'll roll it into everything well you
know where your bridge is it's going to
come out in the 3.5 trillion dollar oh
along with everyone else's little yeah
you know appropriating funds for
individual projects within a large yeah
wouldn't that be great
and then and then the committee says how
much does the transportation department
actually need next year what are all the
projects we have what do they actually
need blah blah blah but we don't do that
we're just like ah we just make up
numbers you know how i've described
what's going on the culture war in the
past i've said it's like imagine there's
a big whirlpool that's spinning around
and we're all in it
and over time it's getting tighter and
and compressing and spinning faster and
faster and faster that's because we're
getting lower in the pool as we go down
it gets tighter and faster maybe maybe
we're circling the drain that's a good
way to put it i think um
in the in the real world the the the
reality is that the information is
circulating faster and faster so
the analogy i love the most is imagine
it's you know the revolutionary era and
the founding fathers are like we're
declare independence and they fold up
the letter and they pour the wax on it
and stamp it and they hand it to the
carrier who rides on horseback to the
boat who puts it on the boat who then
gets the boat on the water for three
months to make it back to the king of
england and then in that three months
have you sent the letter you're sitting
there you're working the crops or you're
you're having meetings and discussions
about independence and then the king the
boat finally lands it takes a few days
to make it to the from the port to the
to the to the to the king into
parliament and then the king reads it
and says oh he had and then he drafts a
letter and he says i reject this we're
sending in troops and then three months
after that
that's how things used to be you would
say we're gonna have a policy position
how many times like if they were
actually gonna go to dc and actually
have a vote they had to physically go
there they'd have discussions and they
weren't hearing all of this stuff all
over the place like if you lived in
virginia and then someone came down from
new york you were hearing things for the
first time up in new york we had a damn
breach and now we've got water flooding
these areas we are not securing our and
then you'd be like i didn't know that
happened you guys ever see the movie
news of the world with tom hanks no
it was a it was a reconstruction era and
he has newspapers from different cities
and he travels around the south with old
newspapers
charging people a dime so they can sit
down as he reads the news that's how
things used to be today what happens is
someone goes on twitter and says abolish
the police and then someone else says i
agree aoc why aren't you abolishing the
police and literally within like 10
minutes she's like i as a representative
think we should abolish the police i'm
not saying literally i'm saying as an
example so we're moving
instantaneously
and then because
she can't get it done in a session
because we're still using this old
system of like you know ian you're
probably like this we're not we're
meeting in person instead of doing
things digitally then people demand if
we can all see the problem why can't we
click a button and fix it why are we
waiting so long for this and then when
it's not getting done they say let's
just bypass the rules of legend of the
legislature joe biden says let me just
rule by executive order and bypass the
supreme court which told me what i'm
doing is illegal but i don't care i'll
do it anyway because we demand instant
satisfaction
whole system is about to burst it's
burst already and now we're just waiting
for the light to reach our eyes but even
the example you used which i liked of uh
the guy from virginia heard heard about
the dam breach from new york
if that was happening in real time
probably the back of his head was like
well
sorry in new york but i represent
virginia yep we don't even have that
anymore proof of that and you mentioned
our beloved alexandria ocasio-cortez
um when she was caught masculist at that
ball a couple weeks ago and her one her
initial response was well like as the
congresswoman from new york like i'm
there for cultural reasons but it's also
my constituency and you say no that was
in manhattan you are queens in the bronx
that museum isn't you're like there is
no constitutional reason for you to say
i represent new york but in her mind i'm
fairly convinced she thinks i am the
congresswoman of new york yep you wish
you were the congress person who i think
would be jerry nadler from i'm right but
i could be wrong i think that's his
dress that you would love for him to
call it and be like uh i'm sorry child
like that's my district
don't talk about my district but that's
what we do now we have members of of of
congress who are passing laws senators
who are passing laws about states that
aren't even represent we want to close
anwar patty murray washington i've told
the senators from alaska to say pass a
bill that says apples are illegal
consider it consider because that's
washington consider this it's back in
the uh let's let's say you know 1800s at
some point early 1800s and someone from
virginia goes to congress and someone
from new york comes down and says we had
a damn breach and he says that i
represent virginia i don't know i don't
tell you you know we want to make sure
we can help our our you know our friends
in in new york so we'll see what we can
do today
you'll you'll get i'll avoid naming the
specific companies but you'll get a
major corporation
going to europe in virginia and say vote
for our bill so we can gut the natural
spring waters in new york yeah you see
it wasn't as easy to transfer money back
then and to communicate as quickly so
you'd have to have a major corporations
spokesman go down to virginia to lobby
specifically
possible it was done it was a lot harder
yeah nowadays you get a linkedin message
you get you get you got a list you get a
bunch of phone calls and emails you get
texts non-stop and there's a guy saying
look you don't care about new york right
you represent virginia great here's what
we're gonna do we we think we should be
able to harvest all the natural spring
water from upstate new york there's
people who live there but don't worry
they're not gonna they're not gonna
sweat it one bit besides there's only a
hundred people up there we are gonna
make substantial contributions to your
political action committees it's gonna
be fantastic you'll love it when you
announce your re-election or when you
announce your election
or a wink wink nudge nudge and then all
of a sudden somebody in virginia doesn't
care about new york says i'm in favor of
the clean water uh usurpion act uh the
theft of water act i think it would be
great if we could share the water with
the country yeah and it's really just
you're bought and paid for yeah like
george carlin i think it was he said we
should put the patches on all over all
over their suits yeah so we know who's
sponsoring them i i just i
i don't think i will ever run for office
i just wish those who represented their
areas had so much more
pride and sense of ownership and sense
of responsibility and sense of
territorialness so that if another
senator or congressperson was trying to
pass
laws or whatever about my area the
response is like no no no this is turf
warfare you know and and and it just
bothers me that
everyone thinks they are the senator of
the country
and there are great examples of that
lindsey graham spends half his time in
afghanistan i i am here because i am the
senator you're the senator from south
carolina a not
hugely significant state no offense to
south carolinians who are watching
lovely state have vacation there many
times but like you're you're the senator
from south carolina stay in south
carolina care deeply about south
carolina but what these guys do is they
run for office and and republicans i
think sometimes are even more guilty of
this and democrats ted cruz has been
senator of america marco rubio has been
senator of america since the day they
got into office they get their funding
from all over the country and a lot of
time their constituents hates them yep
but they raised so much money on the
national level that they keep winning
but the you know it was fascinating the
last ted cruz race where he almost lost
to beto o'rourke which is a whole nother
thing running for governor now
natural-born texans
uh he lost the vote of natural-born
texans he won the republican vote of
people who moved to texas texans didn't
like ted cruz well let's talk about laws
we'll talk about sound policy and we'll
make it about guns i'll take i take the
opportunity to advance our gun
discussion because i like to we have the
story from timcast.com west virginia's
crime rates decline after state adopts
constitutional carry law fbi data
indicates a steady decline in violent
crime since 2016 when the policy was
approved by the state's legislature so i
walk into a gun store and i'm like uh so
what do i have to do to buy a gun like
you got to fill out your nick's form the
national instant criminal check system
uh takes forever
yeah it depends sometimes you can put on
a delay list but sometimes it's 15
minutes i'm always on the delay list
because daniel turner is the most boring
name in the world and there are there
are like 33 000 daniel turner's and i'm
always delayed they got to go through it
so well so sometimes they can be like
come back in a few days or they might
just be like we're you're being
researched give us a few minutes but in
west virginia i'm like okay so i didn't
do i need anything no no i can just take
this weapon right now yeah i can put it
on my belt oh yeah you sure you don't
want to do concealed carry i was like i
can yeah you just put it right inside
your belt and i'm like really yeah it's
west virginia constitutional carry you
can't do it outside the state and they
do recommend you get your concealed
carry permit mean you take the test you
get approved and all that stuff because
it does benefit you that is your
background check so you don't have to go
through knicks anymore you just walk in
and buy but this is the this is the
perfect example
people in west virginia live in a very
different world from people in new york
city and chicago
so when you when you see national level
politicians like basically what we're
just talking about is that there are
senators and they are congress people
for the nation they they actually
literally represent one state or one
district but they fundraise off of
everyone in the world
so for those that missed the previous
segment we're basically saying like some
guy in virginia back in the day would go
to dc
hear about a damn breaking in new york
in new york state and be like i
represent west virginia i didn't hear
anything about this i don't know
nowadays you'll get big corporations
trying to get votes to crush new york
state law by getting a federal law to
like supersede it or by getting support
from other places so this is what ends
up happening you get democrats who are
like we should ban guns i'm like okay
you know what i'll say this first of all
second amendment so you can't just do
that but i hear you if you live in
chicago
and you live in that world
i don't live there anymore i can tell
you what it was like living there
it doesn't make sense for you to pass a
law based on chicago's problems on west
virginia because in west virginia their
crime went down when they told everybody
feel free to carry a weapon around and
the example i always give people when
they're like you know uh we obviously
you know uh we have different properties
here for tim cast
and there are people who you know come
from cities and they're worried about
guns and stuff
i i tell people look
when i go outside and i'm in new york
you you've you guys have been in new
york i imagine of course yeah i used to
live there born and raised
were you scared crossing the street
um
it depends upon what what stage of my
life oh it's just like walk but like
hitting by a car oh god no no we played
it in the street jay walk in the street
break open the fire hydrants and spray
imagine this
in chicago in new york you'll want
you'll be driving around you'll see a
fire hydrant open up and sprang in the
street right you've seen those before
sure it's in the middle of the street
are you not just there basketball people
would put basketball hoops up to the
street they would play in a car comes
the car and they'd move
in chicago we would skate in the street
in a car car and we'd move
imagine looking at this gigantic massive
metal hurtling at you at 35 to 40 miles
an hour or whatever depending on what
part of the city you're in and and then
freezing there are cars everywhere what
do we do when i see people in west
virginia carrying guns i just you don't
even think about it i don't think
someone in the car is going to veer off
the road and slam into me sometimes it
happens and i don't think a guy's got a
gun is going to pull out and just start
shooting randomly but there are people
who live in cities who who feel this way
and all of a sudden now they're using
the weight of the federal government to
go after states where it makes no sense
this is one of the biggest problems
we're facing right now and it's why even
sarah silverman in my opinion is saying
peaceful divorce because if we're at a
point
where you've got democrats being like we
would like to pass laws for new york but
for the country that makes no sense
it's i'll tell you what the problem is
when you see politicians running for
federal office
they want to be in congress like aoc or
anybody else they are running for
federal office and they go i'm going to
clean up this town if you vote for me
we're going to reduce crime rates and
improve schooling and get funding for
our university or you know and
hold on
you're not a local politician you're
running for federal office you're not
you're not representing the district's
interests in terms of how they how they
spend their own tax funds you're talking
about going to congress and voting on
war and budgets which will affect your
district but when they're like i'm gonna
clean up this town no you're not you're
going to dc you're going to be voting on
cleaning up afghanistan or coming back
and cleaning up
syria
you want you want to change those issues
you vote for local politicians what
happens now is people are running for
office on local issues nationally and
then they're saying we've got a gun
problem in chicago so we should ban guns
for people in west virginia yeah
that makes sense do you think that these
politicians and lawmakers started off as
people that had local pride and then
they just got corrupted as they got
involved in the process or do you think
that they were just chills from the
beginning to some extent i think i think
uh um
uh kirsten gillibrand is a great example
of that she was a congresswoman from
upstate new york moderate democrat
uh
hillary clinton moved on uh her seat was
vacant and she got the job and now
kirsten gillibrand is as left-wing as
chuck schumer remember when she was in
the shop
she had a approval rating from from the
nra she had a positive approval rating i
bet you if you ask her now she would
probably be 100
anti-guns in all form because
and that's what separates her from i
think as someone like senator bernie
sanders because vermont doesn't have a
huge city bernie is only rural so bernie
actually on guns is either pretty quiet
or actually probably not that bad but if
you're a senator from a state like new
york kristen kirsten gillibrand and
chuck schumer know they just need to win
new york city they don't care about
albany utica you know
schenectady no one cares about those
places same with california
same same with with illinois right but
if you're from a kind of a state that
has like uh some city but like it's a
rural state vermont the two guys from
from connecticut the two guys from uh um
new hampshire you are maine
you are spelling out why we need the
electoral college absolutely when you
look at states like new york illinois
they say in illinois i don't need to win
anything but chicago yeah and that's all
becoming all of america and that's the
ethos of my organization
powerthefuture.com is the the divide in
america used to the divide in america
growing divide i think in my personal
philosophy i should write a book on this
is between urban and rural and we were
always a rural country that had big
cities but it used to be when i was born
it was 55 45 and in my lifetime that has
flip-flopped and now the majority of us
live in cities and city people are well
thank god but city people are making
policies for the country look at the
green new deal look at the the the
high-speed rail and no combustion engine
that is written by someone who thinks
like a
girl
aoc who has only known the city she is
not thinking of someone who is from
rural west virginia so she says well
just get rid of the combustion engine
and you say well in alaska
a lot of people like a lot of people
have a little tiny airplane because
that's how they get to the grocery store
like it is not uncommon to jump in your
little tiny plane and they buy planes
for what you buy suvs 40 000 you can buy
a used plane i think maybe they don't
really have their license but it's
alaska no one cares they fly they land
they go to the grocery ban the
combination
i think i read somewhere that if we shut
down oil produ all fossil fuel
production
within this year you'd get like 60
million dead within a few months oh
absolutely probably more than actually i
think it's like within a few days 60
million would die mostly because they'd
be unable to power refrigerators all the
diabetics would instantly die because
their insulin would spoil and then you
can't transport food you can't drive
anymore so all of the energy
transportation that grows food
transports food and makes the water work
and like we're they say that we're
addicted to fossil fuels it's not that
we're addicted it's that our
infrastructure is built upon it it's not
an addiction it's a it's an energy
requirement for sustaining this level of
yeah and they have immigration they have
no idea how farming works how ranching
works to manufacture works so they will
say something like the peta folks or the
whatever folks like this is cruel what
you do to animals and could we and
should we treat animals humanely as we
absolutely we should and we should
always strive to be better but the thing
is that you live in the upper east side
of manhattan and you think food is going
to whole foods and buying stuff in my
package and you have no idea what it
took to get that thing look at this this
this is
water in a plastic bottle that was bro
this is not possible but for fossil
fuels
i was talking to someone during the
primary
and it was uh i'm sorry not the primary
yeah it was it it was on a lockdown so
like primer was through a lot throughout
lockdown right wasn't it yeah and i
mentioned something like if we shut down
the economy
how eventually we're going to run out of
food at the stores and i had someone who
was pro like a ubi guy say what are you
talking about we can just go to the
store to get food when we need it
and then i said
if we do ubi
and people don't work and don't make
stuff
and people aren't farming then where
will the food come from and they're like
the store what do you mean oh god
i hope you cut that person
there's twitter it was twitter and i'm
like there are people who are literally
sitting there thinking that like one day
like a little loaf of bread just appears
on the shelf and slowly starts growing
yeah and then you take it and then
another one responds yeah they had to be
trolling you too
oh they gotta be good oh no
please be troll think about how stupid
the average person is yeah i don't
realize half of them are stupid when i
was in first grade we took the iowa
basics and i got nothing in the 99th
percentile so i was like okay i guess we
all got in the 99th percentile because
that's the easiest thing i just there's
just as much questions stuff they
already told me yeah but that's just not
how society works people failed it's
like but they told you this i can't
remember it was the most obvious i was
like here's all the answers now write
them down and how people couldn't get it
i just don't them and when people are
looking at why food prices are growing
up and and covet has a lot to do with
that oil prices has a lot to do with
that inflation but but as you were
saying with this guy who doesn't know
where food comes from
and working in a slaughtering house is
not glorious work right it's probably
really brutal i'm sure it it pays okay
but you know it's not that you're not
going to make a a huge living it employs
a lot of ex-convicts right it employs a
lot of people with records because
you're slaughtering cows um and i know
this having talked to people who do this
who own these companies for a living
and they were making more to stay home
the last year and a half with kovid and
so now you are bringing in beef that is
not getting processed that we're
throwing in the garbage i have a friend
who has five barns and each one of them
has 75 000 little baby chicks that they
raise to a certain size and then the
tysons or companies like that come and
take them off and they process the
chickens and that's why there's always
chickens in the grocery store
but because of cover that was all shut
down and the chickens got too big and
all of the machines that processed
chickens the chicken has to be this big
or this big and now the chicken grew an
extra two months and well you know what
they said and this is my and his mom was
genuinely in tears they said go into
your barns and turn off the ac and close
the door wow and they s and that was
what they had to do and that was the fda
and then what throw them away and then
you throw them away that was the fda
that was like that's what you do
hundreds of thousands of chickens that
are perfectly healthy why because the
government said they're not essential
workers so now people like why is food
so expensive government i want to i want
to talk about cascades
i want to talk about economic cascade
failure
so you may have seen these stories over
the past few months of like people
putting up signs saying we all quit
right
you you were just mentioning that for
the past year so people are getting paid
more not to work so why would they work
i think that plays a role in people not
working so what happens is
we had a story recently another one
where it's like sign appears on a
restaurant we've been working for a
month straight with no days off there's
not enough people here so we all quit
sorry for the inconvenience
when you have a restaurant with 10
people
and that allows you to have rotating
shifts of part-time workers people get
their days off
when three of them end up quitting for
whatever reason leaving for whatever
reason
and now you only you you have less
substantially less staff people have to
pick up shifts
then you say look we have no one else we
need you to come in and then they say i
can't work this many hours i quit
it's a cascade failure where the more
people who quit
the more people will quit meaning more
people will quit
so even though we've ended the covet
unemployment benefits
you ever you ever you ever have like a
drain like a thing of water and you're
like draining the tub and you swirl it
with your finger for fun to make that
spiral that's what we did that's what
the democratic establishment the
governors and many republicans did they
decided that as the economy was being
shuttered they would swirl the water as
fast they could to try and kick-start
that that little whirlpool to to kick
off
as soon as they got a certain amount of
people to quit it it's ignition it
becomes self-sustainable but a better a
better way to put it is they had the
stick in the wood and they are doing a
little thing to get the stick to
friction and they're like we just need
ignition once we get to the point where
we generate enough friction for the
business people will quit once people
keep quitting it becomes a
self-sustaining collapse a cascade
failure of economics and now we're going
to see prices go up i'm seeing i saw
more people today post photos of empty
store shelves yeah yeah that's crazy to
me that has been going on for so long
but you know where i go makes sense when
they talk about a great reset about
people consuming too much and i'm like
well
here it is
people people are going to wake up one
day to 10 milk
and that's when things get crazy so and
it's happening at a bad time because
winter always exacerbates economic
problems right you have you have
transportation problems because of snow
because of ice because of cold um things
are just harder to to to to to maintain
in in winter um
so prices are going to skyrocket not to
mention oil prices gas prices
electricity prices heating prices right
so it's going to be bad they i actually
on the on the drive here they were
already talking on the news about they
have noticed uh an increase in hoarding
tendencies again at big box stores
toilet paper paper towels there's
nothing causing it there's no there's no
something on the horizon but people just
feel it this is the fascinating thing
absolutely people who are paying
attention the people who are paying
attention are feeling it and people are
people are doing it um so yeah we're
headed to some very very very dark times
you want to know how dark it is let me
just pull up this story right here two
men arrested in new zealand for
smuggling kfc into coveted lockdown
auckland okay so not necessarily the
same thing as economic failure but but
come on this is the psychotic nightmare
dystopia story you never thought you'd
see
smuggling kfc why is kfc banned
why can't you have kfc central i don't
know what is that to do with covid maybe
like they were in an area that you're
not allowed to are they in a quarantined
area because their their quarantines
were geographic like you are not allowed
to take out his band take out his band
why because it might have covert on it
okay
so look i highlighted this just to show
hell is happening when when they set
policies and play in into in motion that
create a cascade failure a collapse
this is just another example of the
absurdity of the rules that make no
sense that will just cause people to
lose their minds yeah covet doesn't live
out in the environment for very long i
mean that's pretty i mean
but that's that's besides the point the
point i'm saying is people in government
don't know don't care they're just like
burn it down
just whatever it takes to make people go
crazy and burn it down middle-class
people seeing the prices we went to the
store the other day we were like we want
to get some charcuterie some meats and
cheeses we had the shopping cart maybe
about 20 full and it was four hundred
dollars yes
i get it you know cheese and meat can be
costly but
a year ago we filled up a whole cart
including our standard selection of
meats and cheese we're not buying like
fancy you know french imported meats
like regular salami and stuff we would
fill up the whole card for 40 bucks i
remember a year ago we filled the cart
and we had like beans and rice and meat
and cheese and milk and i was like wow
400 for this that's crazy now it's like
the car's barely full and i'm like what
is happening
i have been photo documenting my grocery
trips because every single time i go i
spend about the same amount and every
time it gets smaller this last time i
filled the seat that the kid sits in
with the food that i was buying for
myself for a week and it was like eighty
dollars and i was like this is not what
i used to be able to buy this is insane
and the stores are the shelves are empty
this is something i noticed too there's
no dairy there's very little beef we
couldn't get cream yeah this bothered me
end of the world cream for my coffee
and we went and uh i like heavy cream i
don't like the half and half it's got a
little sugar in it i don't know i want
like fresh cream and we went to the
store over a month not nothing
and so i asked i was like how do you
have none and they're like it just
doesn't come in and i'm like yeah but
you got cheese and ice cream and they
were like i guess you know they're
prioritizing
they're not prioritizing the heavy cream
because it's like a special use case how
many how much like come on if you go to
the store and you want something with
cream you're gonna get milk you're gonna
get cheese you're gonna get yogurt
you're gonna get ice cream heavy
whipping cream is probably one of the
last things people get and not everybody
puts cream in their coffee like that but
when you're doing keto you know things
like that you're like you want to use
fresh heavy cream less sugars less you
know milk particles and stuff and have
it so we had to go to a different store
and we found
a crummier version that spoiled much
faster
but that that that's something that
really freaked me out because aside from
the cream were these little stars they
put up everywhere that said 500 sign-on
bonus
all over the store i put it on my
instagram you can watch the video i'm
like yo something's wrong
there's a bunch of some stuff like boy
do they got a lot of canned whipped
cream hmm but that's like corn syrup
that's not yeah that's that's
that's oil
some of it yeah a lot of it some of it's
good though some of it's well some of
it's okay it depends on what you but i'm
like i just want fresh cream like i want
to i want to eat healthy and have
i guess if you were to ask someone what
they were going to buy first they'd be
like i'll take the the ready whip you
know whipped cream bottle over the fresh
cream you know what i mean so they are
not prioritizing it or the store wasn't
getting it i went to a couple stores
didn't have it yeah we finally found a
store that did
we got a bunch it didn't last as long
for whatever reason i don't know i'm
like we like the the good organic stuff
i mean we've been doing this as a
country for you could argue almost 400
years or not as a country but as
people on this land
our economy got to a stage of
so well
oiled so supply line genius so it is
really adam smith in operations you know
there's always that expression um
or that like a running joke in the
economic world of how many uh
chinese restaurants can you have on one
block in new york city and the answer is
as many as the market allows right like
like there is no rule like we got to the
point that yeah you could get your heavy
cream your fresh whipping cream without
even thinking about it because all these
literally millions of invisible hands
were all working together making things
happen and all we needed was this one
big government that the thought they
knew better
for your own good have you ever been
we're never it's going to take another
five years to recover from this i feel
like we're in the rat utopia experiment
you're familiar you guys you guys are
familiar with oh yeah no so we had uh
shane who writes uh for our mysteries
and and tales of intrigue for
timcast.com the new shows we're getting
ready to launch soon the podcast version
and one of the stories he wrote is about
the the rat utopia experiment and the
was it the kurt curtis richter was that
his name i think so yeah the rat
experiment that's the hope experiment
but the right utopia was that he he
created space put the rats in it gave
him unlimited food and water and said do
whatever you want and eventually they
they just went nuts started killing each
other
uh things got really bad there was there
was a one group called the beautiful
ones that just groomed themselves and do
nothing else they would all huddle in
the same place just behavior became very
very weird
so what you're bringing up now because i
know we mentioned the right experiment
stuff quite a bit but the point i'm
trying to make is the idea that i'm
put out over the fact i can't snap my
fingers and get my cream it's kind of
insane isn't it
how about back in the day you had to
actually go find a cream sales person or
a farmer who had a dairy farm and you'd
be like spending a few days or you'd
know who the one person was who had it
and you'd be like
you know oh hey honey uh jim says we we
should be ready to pick up our our
supply of cream you know in three days
when it's ready and you just couldn't
get it because it didn't exist now we're
so used to everything at our fingertips
having an over abundance of food and
unlimited supply of ridiculous things
like cream of all things and sugar
candies and unlimited water and we are
living in that utopia and that is the
problem that unfolds a lot of the the
hyperbolic social ills that the left
likes to say are dividing this country
you know systemic racism and and
militants misogyny and sexism and the
response often is we live in the not to
say that there are not ills in society
we live in the time of such privilege
henry viii could not have imagined a
more opulent lifestyle i know i mean you
just look at how many pillow options you
have
yeah i don't know like just one
promo code
like the the level of privilege we have
our the the american poor and this is
another thing if you're doing
international travel especially to
developing countries or like real this
poverty in impoverished countries which
i have
our poor have better quality of life
than the vast majority than literally
half the world
and not to say that we shouldn't make
our poor more prosperous or allow them
to become more prosperous but the level
of prosperity and opulence and comfort
we have is is almost sickening we went
to the mall
and uh i walked in and you get to the
like there's a bunch of the you know
doors and it's like you get to the
middle and there's the
three story so you've got two stories
but that is an even higher dome of glass
and i was like man if you took someone
from like the 1500s and brought them in
they would be like
for what god have you created this
palace yeah like no i'm just buying
sneakers exactly i wanted to get an ice
cream while i was here that's that that
is insane you look at these buildings
look at i tweeted this the other day
look at go to the grocery store and look
at how many orange juice options you
have based upon your tolerance of pulp
and it's like and the people who are
like oh i don't drink pope it's like you
think we're gonna abolish fossil fuels
you know it's like i only do grove stand
no pulp and and
no we're never going to abolish fossil
fuels because your lifestyle dictates
that i like fiji water crystal geyser i
don't like this water this is what we
one of the things we talked about with
uh one of the things i talked about alex
jones the other day was
i think we talked about on the show the
the chicken analogy i like to use i
don't know if it was on the bone i think
it was on the bonus segment prep so
people are getting
we'll tell you the story and then i like
to hear your thoughts on this so you
know alex likes to talk about the
globalists and
depopulation and the the one world and
all the stuff
and i said
you know what if it's true that we're
overpopulating and like yeast in a
bottle we're consuming the sugars and
farting ourselves to death
and so
when we talk about
any kind of these conspiracies here's
what i say
imagine you have 10 chickens
and chickens like to take dumps in their
water you know first hand every morning
when i clean out the water i'm like why
do you keep doing this
i've hung it from string i've put it on
blocks i've made it so to the point that
all you can do is put your beak in it
and they find a way to climb on top and
turn around
every morning
i'm impressed because sometimes i feel
like it's on purpose and they're smarter
than i think but no no look
they're smart enough to realize not to
drink the crap water but not smart
enough to realize not to crap in it
they're the ones now imagine you had 10
chickens and they all keep crapping in
the water so you go in one day and you
do something to train them stop doing it
the next day five of them stopped and
five of them keep doing it yeah are you
which what which chicken
which chickens do you want to breed yeah
exactly not the ones that keep crapping
in their water so i bring that because
you talk about the activists the
environmentalists the the ban climate
you know uh
ban fossil fuels and climate change and
all stuff those are the people in cities
who are the chickens crapping in their
own water
while they're being told to stop doing
it and they keep doing it at a certain
point someone's going to be like i'm not
going to choose to put resources into
those communities that keep crapping in
their water and destroying everything i
would rather invest in communities that
are more self-sustaining guess what it
ain't in the cities
so the like it's like you were saying
these people are saying i want to ban
all fossil fuels but i need 17 variety
of orange juice based on my pulp
consumption yeah
and we peanut butter everything um bread
and we see that growth of of rural
america i mean there is things are
starting to shift suburbs are becoming
which is why there is a big push to end
suburbia heck gavin newsom the day after
he won a re-election changed uh zoning
laws in california to ban single house
uh dwelling zoning laws so neighborhoods
that you could only build a single
family house that's no longer gone
because that's that's they have to get
rid of that shift they need people
concentrated in the cities because that
concentrates their power but people who
are able to a lot of them are going to
other states or just like i did left i
mean
18 years in new york 20 years in dc and
now i live in the middle of the country
i wanted to get the hell away from those
policies you want to be an
environmentalist make a homestead yeah
grow grow as much of your own food as
possible tend to your own garden i mean
look if you've got a septic system in a
lot of ways they're very self-sufficient
you'd have to get them pumped but done
right that they the bacteria can take
care of things for you plus you get well
water you can get some kind of you can
get renewable energy sources to offset
your energy costs and even remove
yourself from the grid yet you go to
these cities and they're the most
wasteful
they they like the air conditioning cost
for some of these cities is so
absolutely insane because they're
completely inefficient it's and i don't
know if you guys you guys have been in
new york you ever see those big nitrogen
tanks they have where they're blasting
nitrogen underground and and the vapor
is coming up from the ground i think
it's nitrogen what i was told and i fact
check man this one because i did this
was just scuttle what i heard from like
a local guy in new york is that the
underground cable infrastructure is so
old it's overheating and melting so they
just wheel in big tanks of nitrogen to
blast nitrogen to cool it off and they
yeah they blast it to cool the cable so
they don't melt
you've got infrastructure so old in
decayed that we are wasting ridiculous
amounts of energy to sustain this system
and we keep building on top of it
those are the people that are voting
nationally to implement rules on west
virginians who have like very little
carbon footprint and tend to their own
chickens and goats and grow their own
corn or whatever they're the people who
will and i know friends who have done
this and i do make fun of them so i
apologize if anyone listening is that
person they are the people who will post
postmates a bagel at 9am to their house
and they will talk about sustainability
and you said you know how many fossil
fuels you just how much waste there is
that you couldn't either walk yourself
or just you didn't buy bread and make
your own little toaster like but i
really wanted they have really good
bagels in this one place and they will
spend eight i know people who have spent
up to 18 for like a bagel with cream
cheese because that's just what they
wanted for breakfast so it's like you're
gonna abolish fossil fuels it's like
wall-e you know the big fat people
sitting in the chairs oh yeah
yeah i i i i know the story about
postmating the bagels man i've seen in
in new york people being like i've
ordered a tea
i've seen people order a bubble tea and
i'm like you had someone come on that
like little electric mo electric moped
that consumes energy
so you can have a bubble tea yeah and
those are the classes we're building now
so there's the elite class there's the
coding class learn to code and we will
have this enormous working class of now
maybe one day you'll be able to post
mates through through in artificial
intelligence
we're not there yet someone is still
cutting open the bagel and putting the
cream cheese on it and putting and
handing it off to the guy maybe we're
what 20 years away from all that being
automatic but as of now we still need
actually it seems like we need the uber
world the we need a growing
unskilled labor which is the not
pejorative sense i mean it in the
economic sense unskilled labor workforce
and why are we importing tens of
thousands of them every month because
that keeps part of that economy going
and people like it i'm thinking about
human behavior and you mentioning like
maybe i'll get to the point the ai
making the bagel or whatever in star
trek you know
captain picard goes d
computer t earl grey hot and then it
just appears in front of them i wonder
about what humans would do if we had
access to that stuff i think people
would gorge themselves to death yes i
think it would
so i think there's a lot of people in
this country that have the ability to
eat whatever they want whenever they
want because they have access to enough
resources to do so and i don't even need
that much money somebody makes you know
mid five figures and they decide to use
their excess cash to just eat
eat but there's a lot of people who
don't have the money to spend to do that
and so they end up thinner simply by
virtue of not having the ability to buy
the food what if everybody had the
ability to walk up to something and just
be like entire cheesecake caramel on top
extra whipped cream pumpkin spice
and you could just keep doing it they
would gorge themselves i wonder if
people would just if they really did
have that kind of level of technology if
we reduced the cost to near zero or did
a ubi and we had ai producing everything
i think people would be like wally
they'd sit in chairs and they'd be like
i wash myself with a rag on a stick
yeah you know that would be an awesome
kind of kind of cruel but an awesome
experiment like imagine if you had to
take someone who was willing to you know
they had to work from home you know and
for you're going to live in this room
for a month here's your job blah blah
blah but when you ask for something
you're going to get it
you know just like we we can't do it
instantaneously we need a little bit of
time but like it's lunchtime what do you
want to eat it's dinner time what do you
want for dinner it's breakfast what do
you want for dinner uh it's movie time
what do you want to watch and you would
wonder if after a day it would be like i
want to watch porn i want to eat this i
want to eat this i want to eat this and
you'd love to know if after the month
the person would come out
dead or if they or if at a certain point
they'd be like i feel disgusting like we
all do that you know like yeah bachelor
party weekend and you're drinking an
open barred even at a wedding but at a
point most of us are like you know what
i'm i'm just can i just have a water
i wonder if people would i'd be curious
to see if you could do it with multiple
folks
how many would just become
that gluttonous disgusting slob you know
i think five five folks from the city
and five folks from the country
yeah you know just just yeah i'd love to
see
i like to think about a certain i know
it sounds like a reality show we should
fund yeah it does yeah now i know like
my i know what my tastes are and i don't
know what i would ask for but i like to
think that by like the third day i'd be
like well i'm not gonna have dessert
again this is brilliant but would i
utopia island
and we take you know yeah five people
from the city five people from the
country
and every morning they can request
anything they want
at all them
i mean obviously you can't get a jet the
point is in terms of your living you
have access to any food any
entertainment you just have to trick
them as all good sociology all good
experiments do you have to trick them to
think that the experiment is about
something else they can't know it's
about their food choices just and part
of this you can ask for whatever you
want to eat but the the experiment of
the 10 of you on this as you have to
build it's a reality show on this
reality show is something else and they
don't know that exactly this is this is
really the experiment i i would fund
that i think that would be
awesome yeah so i want to know the
results of that i would love to see what
people would we would we we
would tell people like the goal of
utopia island is to perform tasks and do
acts
and then as an aside we'd say you know
uh put in any order for any kind of food
you want if you have a craving for you
know blue cheese burger onion rings
anything like that you want a steak let
us know and we will get whatever food
whatever entertainment one shows because
we want people working on the show to be
comfortable yeah i'd love to see if it
confirms stereotypes like there's the
guy from boston always like lobster and
chowder yeah like you know does the guy
like is the italian always like getting
pasta i'd love to know but like i think
confirmed region more than ethnicity you
know like somebody who grew up so
big is always getting a cheesesteak
again seriously you have to measure for
them like if you eat a sandwich and i
see you eating it there might be
something in my mind we're like i want
that and if i smell onions on your
breath i'm like man i want onions you
know that so we gotta you have to
isolate them when they eat and then make
sure that you don't smell each other's
foods not at all because otherwise
literally at any time you can ask us for
food and we will get it for you but then
they might not go with what they want
just whatever they see in the moment
that's irrelevant well it might taint
the study why would it take the study
because you don't know what their real
choice like it changes there is no real
choice it's literally like like
when people are in a in a group
when people are on an island that's not
the point of the study the study is we
will give you access to any food at any
time of the day you let us know
uh we're here for you just let us know
what you want literally you name it you
want tiramisu we'll get you tiramisu you
want to you want a whole cheesecake
we'll get you a cheesecake just
literally tell us you would be curious
to know if like your tendency is to be
healthy like i'm not going to smell your
salad and suddenly crave salad but like
if you smell my chocolate cake would you
something be like that smells really
good oh yeah people have chocolate
people go in the fridge and they're like
what's in here i'll eat that yeah
so but i've got to do a control study
i'm thinking of freezing salad with
cranberry pie nuts and spirulina there
you go i mean i think i think would you
be surprised i think there'd be a lot of
people it's just
green it's a seaweed and it's one of the
healthiest foods on earth now here's
spirulina it's like an algae isn't it
yeah here's the funny thing could you
imagine somebody comes in like a working
class person moderately like average
weight and they're like i can order
anything you literally tell us what you
want to eat while you're on the show we
take care of you because so that you can
oh
i'll take a t-bone i'll take a mashed
potatoes and some asparagus it's like
you got it we come back i'll take a
dessert you know you want a dessert
absolutely apple pie ice cream done done
pumpkin spice you know cake with carrot
cake or whatever and then by the end by
the end of the month they're like 40
pounds overweight
i think i think you'd find it i think
it'd be curious to see if people would
gorge themselves if they were given
unlimited options or do you have like
the question is does the human
individual have the ability to
[Music]
uh
regulate itself or is again we're back
to lock and hobbes or is it the society
that regulates you is it you looking at
me when we have 2 p.m check-in that
you're like whoa turning you got a
little chunky there you know like am i
not eating because i see that you see
that i got fat or am i not doing it
because of my own self-awareness here's
another idea
we also have a plant who does nothing
but eat non-stop
not slovenly not like
but just being like whenever they see
him he's got like fr you know he's got
like brad pitt in ocean's eleven do you
ever
so they walk in and he's got like a
thing of mac and cheese and he's like
hey how's it going you know what's been
going on and then the guy walks in he's
got a cheesecake and he's eating and
then someone sees i'll take a cheesecake
too
and then this person secretly is just
exercising full speed and you know so
they're always looking really good but
they're always eating non-stop we could
do it with animals we could try you know
they're like you know there are certain
dog breeds that they call free feed that
people that just leave food and when the
dog is hungry it will go if i did that
to my dogs
they would eat until they threw up they
would eat the throw up they would eat
and that's and they like you cannot have
food around they're very well trained
they wouldn't ever eat my food but but
i'd be curious to see if if humans have
that like certain dog breeds some do and
so can i can i legally do a chicken
utopia experiment oh so we're building
the new chicken city it's going to be
fully enclosed because we have a fox
yeah and then a hawk just recently
attacked and then roberto went and then
all the chickens ran inside so we're
like okay we'll do the chicken run we'll
do the whole thing covered you can walk
in it but you have to go through the
door
what if we just let them keep having
babies well you know what i'm gonna do i
want to get a big huge
maybe like 50 gallon food thing that we
just fill up and they just eat the food
and the food comes down and they keep
eating it i think it doesn't spoil as
long as it stays dry right yeah i've my
chickens i have every now and then gone
out and and there's still food in their
bowls because they're just they like to
peck at the grass and they like to peck
at bugs i don't see them eating to the
point that the food is gone my dogs yes
but but my the point is if we give
chickens access to unlimited food and
water and they keep having babies will
it turn out like the rat utopia will
chickens as different kind of animal be
yeah they're not have a different
chromosome right birds zw or something i
don't know will they will they have a
different reaction to a limited space
but unlimited resources
no
they stopped
even the racers will fight each other
even your your three chickens that are
too small to be in the public but are a
little too big for like they they want
out because their space is getting small
so yeah they they need if their space is
limited they'll start getting crazy when
they get on top of each other yeah yeah
that's the challenge because we got
three of the babies are fully feathered
now i think they're at seven weeks about
but they're not big enough to be with
the rest of the chickens because they'll
get attacked that's the problem when
they start breeding at different times
that's why you have to control your
roosters you know we can do that all
these different ages and it's too much
we just we let the older ones out of the
enclosed coop and then close the door so
they're in the run and then with the
little ones out in the enclosed section
to run and do chicken stuff
yeah it's it's a tight space in there
for them because we got we have five
black star babies now they're special
special breed yeah the the girls
every inch of their bodies are black
except one of them has one white feather
that's a big part of the rat utopia
experiment is the lack of space they're
stuck in a space so they have infinite
stuff that might not be a problem like
new york right your space is limited
like earth
we're stuck here right now yeah people
people keep trying to go higher but
you're still
yeah you're still stuck yeah if we could
somehow remove that from the study
that'd be interesting studying
might not be any social issues at that
point i have tried to convince people as
you know
i'm uh about two hours outside of dc and
i've had a lot of friends come for the
weekend and they talk about how it's
almost therapeutic right i think i think
one of the biggest problems with dc or
new york or any city is that many people
never get a chance
to not live in that when i think of new
york i think of gray like looking
through gray air because it's so dirty
from the i just imagine the grayness of
that city and i think it's the brake
dust and the lack of light right i mean
when you have when every building is 70
80 90 stories
you you live in the shadows a lot it's
very hard to get some that's why people
flock to
central park there's not a lot of
sunlight especially in the midtown area
so
yeah you just you're surrounded by huge
tall oh new york people people don't
understand it's it's it's tough it's
tough it's worth seeing once imagine an
apartment where your only window when
you look out is a brick wall why because
it's within like five feet of the other
building there's nothing to see outside
your window but a brick wall and you're
locked in there for like a year and
you're paying forty eight hundred
dollars a month for it yeah people lose
their minds yeah it's like solitary
control but they don't know they're
losing their minds that's the crazy part
a lot of times when you're losing your
mind you don't realize you're losing
your mind it's just things to start to
seem you get angry at stuff you get less
little tolerant you know that's losing
your mind that's an aspect of losing
your mind yeah yeah getting back to that
theme that we always return to people
getting mean just wait and see how mean
they are when the prices keep going up
and the scarcity really kicks into place
that's when that's when you're going to
see a lot of mean spirited us just
yeah if if alex jones is right
then i hope you guys are getting out of
cities
yeah done yeah people are just nicer in
the cities and quite frankly when i go
grocery shopping
everyone's got a got a gun nicer in the
city
outside of the cities you know when i go
to the grocery store
you know you know a lot of people are
concealed carry and it's just nicer
people are friendlier because they're
they're they're a country folk i'm a big
proponent and like i said i'm a city kid
i'm multi-generation city kid i am i'm a
becoming a country boy but i
am happier in the country than i ever
could have been in the city it's really
a different lifestyle it's funny when
you're with city people in the country
and they'll point out to you someone's
gun they'll be like oh yeah that guy's
got a gun yeah and i'll be like okay
yeah yeah but yeah he's got a gun and
i'll be like i know half the people here
probably can't see him you mean he's
open carrying we can see yeah you don't
need to tell us
well you know i'm not gonna pretend to
be some country boy either i grew up in
the city i've only been out here for a
year i was in um northeast ohio i grew
up in in the suburbs chicago falls and i
kind of always loathed to the country
because it was like less technology you
know i like to play video games we go to
my aunt and uncle's house in the country
and it was like it was just boring there
was cows you know there were fields it
smelled stinky and there was nothing to
do um for me because i was a city boy
but then i went to the city i loved it
then the internet came out and now it's
like fresh air fresh air is number one
yeah fresh air man i smelled that dank
stank for so long in new york city it
started to destroy my mind i mean
yeah and silence which i think we as a
society have less tolerance for silence
that's why how many people couldn't get
through the entire uh movie what was the
movie where they weren't allowed to talk
because the aliens
people i know couldn't get through it
because it was just it was too quiet you
know i mean how many people walk with
you you know what amazing when you see
people driving with earbuds in
and and you don't even put on the radio
like it's just people are constantly
certain are younger people and then it
sounds like an old folk are you young
folks but our younger people are
bombarded bombarded by sounds
non-stop
internet phone music
silences is is key to any thoughtful
person and you don't find a lot of
silence in the city when we go outside
at night we hear really weird things
those weird bugs yeah yeah it's like
it's it's kind of fun
aren't they coming no no oh stink bugs
are bad yeah they are supposed to get
the funny thing is the bugs are back i
have the air conditioning on like
invasive species from china
yeah yeah
bug i have ac on full blast oh i know
and it's like 75 outside and 60 in the
house and they're still trying to come
in and then they get cold and fall to
the ground like the bars
why are you coming into my freezing
house i don't understand that it's i
guess it's instinct they go inside
to escape you know for the winter but
then it's colder inside the good news is
chickens absolutely love it i'm just
gonna say that try to catch them and
they play like stink bug rugby you just
hate the ground and they run you give it
a little shake so he's not oh sorry this
is mean
throw them down and the chickens we
gotta build one of those male tubes
where you like put the mail in it sucks
it but for stink bugs from so we can put
them up
send it over to the city
let's go super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button
and uh subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends go to
timcast.com become a member for those
exclusive tim cast irl segments you
don't want to miss the hour and a half
we did with alex jones yesterday that
was fun that was a big conversation we
knew it was going to go along because
i have no control over the conversation
when alex jones is in the room but uh
let's see we got here uh i do want to
shout out toby walker who said malort is
actually amazing omg
well we have a lot of malort
and uh just wanted you to know
um maybe we'll we'll do we'll we'll open
it on the vlog and talk about it what is
it exactly it is a wormwood liqueur oh
cool yeah and apparently it tastes
really really bad all right and my
response was like i think all alcohol
tastes bad so i'm not sure this would be
a special rotten
i took a sauna like a few weeks ago yeah
it's like rotten food is what alcohol is
um and then i got out of the sauna and i
felt so clean and i sipped on the beer
and it tasted rotten it was the first
time i ever sipped on alcohol and it
actually tasted like rotten food i was
like
yeah i don't like alcohol at all i think
it all tastes really bad what do you
think the sauna did to your taste buds
cleaned out like it cleaned out a bunch
of something i don't know wow that was
incredible i mean that's really that's
awesome i mean after i sit i sit a
little bit more and i could no longer
taste the rottenness it just tasted like
beer again okay wow that's crazy all
right dogbert says tim i sent you an
email about nft and your show with astro
zero nft we would love to work with you
we're actually planning on doing uh we
have portraits of all of our guests and
creating digital nfts of all the
portraits from all of our guests they're
all autographed as well and ian's
working on that stuff it's very very
exciting very exciting we've got like um
we haven't i didn't see we have an alex
jones one though i'm pretty sure we have
we have an alex jones one we got and we
have polaroids that we take and it's
really it's really an opportunity to
create lots of crazy little bits of art
and and then just sell them you know but
basically
i was explaining to somebody how
revolutionary an nft is
so when it came to cryptocurrency
cryptocurrencies for the most part are
fungible
back in the day of the internet you
wrote a song that song could be copied
infinity you just just you could keep
copying it and sharing it around then
cryptocurrency came along and all of a
sudden there were hard digital assets
that could not be copied but many of
them with nfts you have one existing
object so you could make like one of 30.
so when we take we take a digital
version of these portraits that are
autographed there is only one digital
version in existence there's a physical
version and a digital version and so
we're creating the digital version that
only one person can own at a time but
someone can still copy the picture so
you can still save the picture and have
a copy of yourself but only one person
will own the original digital copy
exactly so a copy of a famous painting
sure people might want to buy to hang up
but it's not the original right exactly
original is the one worth 50 million
bucks so having that original nft
sanctioned by the author that's right
all right let's read michael fernando
melo says san jose got worse people pee
crap and leave used wolf adult
prophylaxis in front of my home yuck
lots of homeless a man was murdered a
block from my home i've joined the bay
area mises caucus to be uh to become a
delegate need to leave cali cool wow
that sounds terrible get out
geeks
all right let's see
trinidad i shop at a pressure better
calf care says yay this is for sour
patch lids passing up sour patch kids
yes thank you thank you
all right
oregon life says tim you called me a
coward last week you live in the middle
of nowhere hiding by the camera censored
by big tech take off the beanie coward i
mean if i was really a coward why
wouldn't i just do like political uh
consulting for big networks where i can
tell them like here's how you build a
big network go ahead and lie to people
why should i challenge the establishment
and put a risk on my neck i'll tell you
what if i wanted to work as hard as i do
why wouldn't i just make i don't know
like a minecraft channel why bother
getting involved in the culture war and
defending liberty and freedom and
critical thought
there are a lot of people who um
would prefer
to chop the tree down today
so that they may have a comfortable
chair to sit in tomorrow
and there are a lot of people that would
plant a tree whose shade they know they
will never sit beneath so that their
children will have a beautiful tree with
fruit and shade and just sit on the
ground let's just sit on the ground
instead yeah i'm dying to grow some
trees don't let chairs don't last
forever what i mean is
you know people would say
i am going to sacrifice my principles
today
so that i can live comfortably today as
well
and that's not a good idea if i if i
really wanted to make tons of money i
could have just stayed working for
disney
i could have said you got it guys put me
on whatever tv show you want i will play
ball no problems from me instead i said
hey you guys are hypocrites and liars
and i'm not going to lie on camera and
they went okay well then
you can't do anything i guess and i was
like okay
and then i was like can i quit no and i
was like well okay then my contract
ended and i was like i'm quitting
they're like okay
and there you go
so i don't know you know you do what you
gotta do
billy long says
joins stream late ian quote we could
actually have a prostitute on the show
oh you got there right in time
there we go
says israel has been developing a laser
replacement for iron dome called the
iron beam
it should be up by the new year the lack
of funding for iron dome may accelerate
the development of the system and we may
see it in action sooner wow a laser
replacement would be substantially
faster and more efficient hardcore you
would probably not even see it it would
be infrared although it would happen is
the rockets from gaza would go pop pop
pop pop pop pop because things go
that'd be cool instantly it's going no
no no no
yeah laser weapons unlike in the movies
travel the speed of light in the movies
they're slower than bullets which is the
weirdest thing
that i never understood
yeah
aaron taylor uh tabor says birthing
persons of the night ah yes agreed thank
you apologies apologies
lathan crafts is a real discussion on
legal sex work would be interesting it
would be interesting you should talk to
alice little who is the most successful
legal sex worker in nevada
yes i think it would be uh
important to talk about
jeremiah jensen says hey titan crew i
finally joined the members page and tim
cast titman crew take off the youtube
filter and show their real true opinions
it's a great show everyone should join
i'll put it this way
we on this show we are careful about the
arbitrary editorial guidelines of
youtube
but
at least i'll say this we try to make
sure anything we talk about on this show
is true in honest opinions but if we're
going to talk about certain issues
we want to be open and we when we're
worried about getting shut down our
censorship we put it on timcast.com so
there is a there is a conundrum but the
you know to youtube being censorious and
violating the rights of people to
express themselves
i suppose the challenge is youtube is
the culture war battleground
it is
we can say on principle i quit and then
completely lose all resources and access
and influence in the culture war or we
can say i'm going to reallocate a large
portion of the workday towards a private
place a speakeasy as it were and then
show people on youtube here's how you
find the speakeasy and hear the ideas
where you can go and more importantly
when people are like jim you know you're
on youtube and you should quit it's like
united alex jones on three times but
steve bannon twice you know they they
can't do their own youtube channels at
the very least we're able to provide
some kind of safety boat where ideas can
still happen even if people disagree
with them it's not perfect you know i
wouldn't i would like to get off youtube
and we're working towards building
timcast.com for that reason but i still
think there's value in having a platform
where we can have guests like alex jones
and steve bannon who actually aren't
allowed on the platform they're not
allowed to have their own platform but
we can host them
all right brandon taylor says if you
guys thought to start a record label to
add another branch to the culture that
you are building or a separate channel
promoting bands
yes
just not now you know so we have to get
to that point yeah it seems like the age
of labels is kind of coming to a close
record labels you know trying to snag
someone profit off of them it's kind of
an insidious
i disagree i think there's a lot of
people who are good at making music and
not good at business well that's for
sure yeah so they need uh help they need
someone who can be like because it's
fair you know they got they got rocked i
was gonna say yeah they got they got
messed up by the record industry a lot
of billy joel lost like a decade of
income from his record contract
john christian says elijah schaefer and
sydney watson new show already taken
down and suspended from youtube just
nine days in but but a strike or what
two strikes two strikes already nine
days
what are they what happened they were
talking about child mass mandates and
they showed studies or something that's
what i saw from sydney that's all it
took yep doesn't take a lot
start up your website you guys yes get
your after show going that's right
it's the way forward wow
nunya bidness says tim poole quote big
tech and media won't attack the left
because they'll literally show up and
burn their houses down also tim poole
the right the right must not use
violence because it doesn't help
all uh what you what you missed in that
quote to nunya business is tim poole
quote also
the left controls the cultural
institutions and when antifa gets
violent they're defended by big tech and
by media the right doesn't have that
opportunity and is fighting an uphill
battle we're in an era where after the
black lives matter riots happened they
lost from they went from 25 net support
to three losing seven percent from the
year prior which were their gains they
have generated a massive opposition
because of their riots so the last thing
you need to do is create propaganda for
your enemy especially when you know that
the right could go outside and wave a
little flag and they'll scream nazis
marched and antifa can burn down a cafe
killing a guy and they'll say peaceful
protest so when when you gain control of
cultural institutions come back and make
arguments
until then
all right let's see
john josh fitzgerald says tim you
definitely have to do a show for up for
us up here in canada we somehow just
elected the king of blackface again yep
that was really impressive to me i'm
impressed
canadians are big fans of that stuff the
canadian people like blackface you know
because you know the reason i say that i
genuinely mean this the first time he
did it people complained about it and
i'm like oh okay i mean i understand why
they're upset but what about like the
third instant now three is it three so
many photos yeah yeah
and so it's like the second time you can
have people if people chalk it up to
like okay we get it it's bad but the
third time and they vote for them i'm
like they like it yep come on action
speak louder than words they like it
yeah they're racist if you did a show in
canada um what would it be a boot
uh sorry i just had two french fries
canadian friends i had to say
you need poutine
and
it's just a french fry place like they
had bacon cheddar french fries and i'm
like yeah we have that at hot dog stands
you know and you can the funny thing is
i'll tell you this poutine in canada is
legit yeah and i've gone to places in
the us that claim to have poutine and it
is not they do have french fries with
like mozzarella balls on top exactly
that's not it montreal is one of the
best food scenes in the world yeah in
the world let alone
the opportunity where this place called
dusty's in l.a and it was a french
canadian restaurant poutine they're from
montreal man that was great cool great
boots but i went to a poutine place and
they had like you know um
pull barbecue pulled pork french fries
and i'm like a lot of that is just
putting stuff on french fries
here but it was really good
cheddar bacon chicken bacon ranch all
that stuff yeah of course but i gotta go
i think the classic is where it is uh
i'm not a big poutine connoisseur i'm
sure all the canadian people watching
are like dude this is how you do it
maybe we should make some some poutine
yeah it's probably pretty easy to make
actually yeah cheese curds
okay so can you can you eat fried french
fries can you keto i didn't say it you
know i said we shouldn't oh you should
make them okay
ian made a paw paw bread i tasted a
little bit i'm not gonna eat it i would
eat when i would eat the poutine i'd
just kind of eat the cheese and the
gravy
you know give you a lot of that
that sounds really good i am hungry yeah
dude
billy long says daniel absolutely killed
it all tonight love the show keep it up
guys ian shouts from cleveland go browns
thanks billy long i was actually just in
cleveland last week what'd you do over
there i
bet a potential donor
oh nice
for the company for my organization yeah
because they were a non-profit we have
to raise money nice um i went to the
steakhouse called red and it was
fantastic awesome can people donate to
your organization and and cleveland yes
they can at powerful.com and cleveland
has as my first time there has stunning
beautiful turn of the century
architecture it's incredible growing up
in the 80s it was like cool it was kind
of run down and then there's
transformation in the 90s man i think it
was the cleveland indians brought lots
of money into that city in the 90s some
beautiful buildings like really
beautiful buildings it was a great place
it was great to walk around and it's i
traveled a ton for work sorry i know you
want to go back to the two um really
quickly i travel a ton for work and i'm
and all over the country all the time um
they are handling the homeless slash
vagrancy problem better than almost any
other city i've seen i was surprised how
clean the streets of cleveland were
whereas cities of comparable size oh
holy cow but cleveland i i was really
impressed i thought it was great what is
their leadership in cleveland are they
really democrat too no idea i'd be
curious we got to find out no idea yeah
me too all right so veron sol says hey
tim i got a friend who does frame and
fact checking on a daily basis i
understand you're trying to start a
non-profit for exactly that how would
one apply and how would you say one
would demonstrate expertise in order to
get an interview samples
uh you would apply by going to jobs at
timcast.com in an email and let me
explain the plan uh we've already filed
paperwork for a non-profit
it will do fact checking analysis it'll
do a general analysis of news outlets
like we're going to take 100 articles
we're going to look for
ethics violations using this the spjs
ethics and then if it's an opinion piece
but it's not labeled opinion they get
they get an x if they're falsely framed
or factually incorrect they get an x if
they try to harm people like here's the
address of a man who posted a meme then
they'll get an x and then you'll see
like out of the 100 articles we read 37
were deemed to be ethical journalism and
then we'll list a spreadsheet of all the
articles each with an explanation that
you can read and assess yourself
now let me explain
frame checking in the easiest way
possible
easiest way you might believe well you
guys probably don't cause you're smart
people but there are a lot of people
that believe that border patrol agents
were whipping
migrants
why
instead of publishing headlines that
read border patrol did not have whips
and were not whipping migrants
all these outlets said white house
condemns border patrol whipping migrants
why because the white house said we
condemn those horrible photos we saw
someone says did you see the photos of
migrants being whipped we saw them
they're horrible we don't know the
context headline white house condemns
whipping migrants
framing it as though it actually
happened
proper framing would be
no comma border patrol agents did not
have whips and did not whip migrants
within the story you would say the white
house when asked not knowing the context
erroneously concluded that it happened
and that the photos were shocking in
reality they were not equipped with
whips they were spinning the reins
that's it they were holding the reins
with a horse and when they move they
spin it i guess they say it's a
technique to keep people from getting
too close to the horse
that's it interesting so that's framing
it's really clever things you can do to
trick people wait so they were they were
snapping them with leather reins they
weren't slapping anybody without
anything they didn't hit anybody without
using them that's how you yeah that's
how you used to you're saying they do it
to keep people away they're on the horse
and they'll spin it so that people don't
come up to them they're not running up
to them and whacking them with it
so it's defensive versus offensive
deterrence but it's like yeah it's the
yeah they spinning spinning the rain is
a big cry from having a whip and
slapping something oh yeah
horse is different than attacking them
but these media outlets know
that they can legally get away with
saying white house condemns
you know border patrol agents whipping
migrants because we didn't say they
whipped migrants we said the white house
condemned it
we didn't say the white house claimed it
was actually happening you know it's
like i condemn ian you know mercilessly
beating children of course but i didn't
do it i didn't say he did oh you're
right you just condemned it
right yeah you know i condemn it wait
but i didn't say he did it yeah you made
a good point daniel that the bad optics
bad media leads to bad policy often and
that they could end up making some dumb
rule like border patrol can't be riding
on horses anymore they probably will
yeah that's the stupidity that can come
out of these misinformation so yeah
all right keep it up yeah jay tiger says
tim with all the union workers
protesting again today they have shut
down construction for two weeks now in
melbourne we had a 6.0 magnitude
earthquake who's going to fix all the
broken buildings wow not the union
workers wow
man melbourne just had a 6.2 magnitude
earthquake yeah
in the past hour or two oh gosh oh wow
like literally as we're talking
oh wow 6.0 is like not that bad that's
not that bad but that's that's that's
you'll feel it yeah is it like
magnitudes that's their magnitudes yeah
times ten every number exponential
increase though beyond once you get to
seven you're out it's nasty nasty like
bringing i don't understand i don't know
the full numbers but i read somewhere
that like the difference between a nine
point zero and nine point one is the
difference between like a 6.0 and like
an 8.9 whoa you know like that it's a
massive difference between non-linear
yeah yeah exponential gain scaler
no legs no problem tv says just brought
a new bought a new sidearm here in
kentucky tragically lost in a boating
accident oh no as a concealed carrier in
kentucky that's all you need to walk out
with your new sidearm sorry about your
all right
that's tragic tragic boating accident
happens to the best of us
okay let's see we got
john kersten says we need daniel and
post to take a trip back to alaska with
a film crew to make a documentary make
it happen tim yeah be awesome
and film
actually we have we have talked about
doing it especially to tell the story of
those people in the pebble mine village
um and i think he's interested in doing
it oh we have we i think i think jack's
coming tomorrow yeah he's here tomorrow
yeah we'll uh you know we'll talk after
the show yeah that would be a great idea
awesome yeah awesome once they have
starlink up and running we'll bring the
whole crew
we'll all go to alaska but you know
we'll get there i hope mr wiggles says i
know you like star trek but i'm a
warhammer guy we are heading to a grim
dark future like warhammer 40k where
there is no good really outside of you
trying to survive but in the end all
sides are seen as bad are you guys
familiar with uh i played a lot of
warhammer growing up yeah warhammer 4000
space marines uh gray wolves uh there's
it's like uh the humans have evolved i
don't really don't know too much about
the lore to be honest there's this thing
called tyranids they're like these these
ant large ant creatures that have
psychic powers that's pretty cool
oh interesting x runner 55 says
shortages are hitting baltimore heavy
cream uh is b zip code i don't know what
that means read the book buy zip code oh
it's buy zip code read the books
accident culture and see how bad things
are interesting really
all right yeah
danimal bungie says i would 100 take a
kamala harris presidency over a biden
presidency because at least then we
could have a chief executive who has
something to lose hmm
interesting
that's a thought
sneaky breeze says the republic isn't
over yet article 5 was created in case
the feds got hungry with power please
try to contact mark meckler to get on
the show so he can promote the
convention of states action
sounds very interesting i'm very
interested in that i'll look this up
lacey ferguson says joy reed claims the
only reason everyone is talking about
gabby petito's death is because of
missing white girl syndrome i can still
feel my brain cells dying
you know so uh one of the one of the
cast uh castle crew members brett
he made a point earlier it was like
didn't we just have people riding nearly
burning down the country because a black
man was killed by the police like
i'm like that's actually a really good
point
i do think the gabby potato potato story
is like not national news i'm sure it's
news in the local area and this is the
family but when i've heard the story and
they were like she was an influencer i
tried finding her her pages and it was
difficult because
she doesn't she has like her instagram
got big afterwards there's no youtube
presence
there's very limited social media
presence relative to
most people i know who are trying to be
influencers so i was like this seems
weird like what terrible terrible word
influence or such a terrible word yeah
but like you know social media
entrepreneur you know i was like why
can't i find anything on this person
they're claiming this person was like a
prominent influencer and i'm like i
but i guess it's tick tock was
tick-tock
i don't know if she was on tick tock but
people on tick tock work
waste of mind space that stupid story
i'm so angry that that is up and about
like it's two idiots beat each other up
one of them got killed the other one and
like now we're not talking about the
surrender in afghanistan like this is
something to to twist everybody's focus
on to like mm-hmm
i when i saw it when i people when the
story started trending again like
getting big i just google searched women
missing minus gabby and there's just
like an endless list of stories
somebody's looking out that's where like
23 year old woman gone missing 25 year
old woman missing with husband and i'm
like this one for some reason caught
fire i do wish joy reed stopped getting
any notoriety she barely has any viewers
most of her notoriety comes from people
who talk about her and not actually her
she's an awful homophobic racist
miserable angry woman and i just wish
she would be canceled and so i get
frustrated when people say do you know
what joey reid said last night because i
just she shouldn't no one should no one
should be watching her
tynan nicholas says went to see kohide
and the used saturday bert mccracken of
the used referred to the unvaxed as
bio-terrorists
the crowd cheered yelling things like
let them die kick their ass and let's
get them the rhetoric is nuts
and genocide much wow
you see have you guys seen the uh the
kaiser chiefs video
no you have not seen it
it's the apocalypse man
so you have the guy from the kaiser
chief and he's got this big crowd of
people in the thousands and he goes let
me see your hands and then everyone
raises their hands and goes wash your
hands we all have clean hands
everyone's holding their hands up and
one guy's going like this with his eyes
closed and like that's
nonsense and he goes let's hear it how
many of you have fives
how many of you have madonna
he goes let's hear it for the
anti-vaxxers
the part when he was like clean hands
you all washed your hands i was like wow
this guy's doing a
service service these people are
testifying to pfizer
one of the creepiest things i've ever
seen and the crazy thing about it is
when you look at their faces when you
see the faces of them like
they're on the verge of crying with
their eyes closed like yes
wow i can't get into these crowds man
all my whole life i was a musician and
an actor but i can't stand going to
shows and standing there and watching
then at the end everyone's like
like these monkeys like screaming and
dancing like what the what is this brain
that's so weird up people can be like
that why why do you scream like that for
like something i don't get it that's
true yeah i never understood that either
oh
all right sorry you know you know you
know you know what i would do
you know what i can do here's what we'll
do
i'll i'll book a show or like an
introduction for one of these groups and
i'll come out and go let me get a ba
from everybody in the audience
yeah
let me hear that bleach
and they all start doing it bad
yeah that's right your sheep look at you
proud of yourself
let me hear that bleach
we should make that a thing just get
everybody to do it yeah
all right let's see
dan gander says tim the ap is officially
censoring negative news re venezuela
minutes of the 2019 meeting show a
resolute uh
okay i can't
resolution to that end introduce
lariva presidential candidate for the
maoist and vz psl easily verifiable
it's hard to read when you uh
use acronyms for everything but you're
trying to cram too much into super chat
so hopefully i did my best
all right robert knight says i've been
trying to relay information to you
regarding evergrand to the info email
blackrock owns a good-sized stake in
evergrand
really that sounds like really bad news
i heard they were going to default do
you guys hear that ever yeah they've
been evolving buildings have been
blowing up i don't know blackrock owns a
good-sized stake in everything yeah i'm
in agreement yeah
i know me too all right the jaded
kriegsman says tim the great divorce may
be a blessing in disguise it gives us a
chance to bring government back to the
level that people have more control of
it look up bigness is badness the case
for a national divorce by fh buckley
it would be
bad in the sense that china would
immediately you know sweep in and yep
start
taking places over china would go to
oregon and washington and be like we're
going to invest heavily in your states
and they're going to be like done deal
right now the u.s government can be like
no you can't do these things well to be
fair china is investing in property and
they're buying up large swaths of
farmland and they're buying up companies
and they're paying off uh professors to
leak you know scientific research to
them so
sure
whatever i guess at this point we don't
have a strong enough central government
to do anything about it so maybe
decentralization would be the better
thing for us
all right kyle abram says ian is a great
crystal shop in shepherdstown near you
called the wings of dreams so happy to
have the crew in my area welcome guys we
need more entrepreneurs like yourselves
build here that's awesome we are
separate rocks what is it called wings
of dreams you should check it out i
think you call it shepherd's town
rocks
that's a cool name for you no he's yeah
i agree yeah
does rock
wings of dreams like it nice name dan
boot says we need to repeal the 17th
amendment and the reapportionment act to
dilute the votes in congress and four
senators to represent their states
i think rep appealing 17th is a good
idea
you know 17 those yes
popular vote for senators brilliant idea
i mean we've we've tinkered so much with
the original structure of our government
then we're surprised it doesn't work so
we just keep tinkering with it yeah well
i mean we can't make amendments that's
what they're for but i think at this
point we can be like hey that one wasn't
a good idea yeah but if
if your two senators were working on
behalf of the governor for the good of
your estate well not at the legislature
and and or
your state you would vote for your local
state wonderful and your reps would then
vote for your senators and the reason
that's a better idea is that people
right now can't name who their local rep
is right they don't care
so they're complaining about local
issues voting for a senator go to
washington to represent them to fix
issues that aren't
lo that aren't going to be done at the
national level so what you need to do is
focus on who your local people are and
then they send people to the federal
government i think that makes more sense
because you're still voting for
representation but it's only about where
you live and your specific local area
right now people are ignoring all the
local issues and it's becoming a
disaster
but i suppose the people who want a
stronger centralized national power like
that idea yeah 17th was what it was
around it was in the early 1900s that's
that that's uh that's all if i'm pretty
sure it was woodrow
wilson of course but this was all part
of the progressive movement and look at
what's next now is as get rid of the
electoral college right and it's just it
is just getting rid of local government
they don't like local government they
like worst central dc government worst
president biden buchanan or wilson
most people most people that i know
they're like freedom oriented like
libertarians say wilson yeah
biggest fascists most fascist president
i i don't think it's fair to say biden
yet because i do think history requires
a little bit of of removal from that
only comes with time so he's as of now
he's an awful president i i'm surprised
how bad he is i didn't think he could be
worse than obama um
so i would have to go wilson
but come back to me in 20 years mustang
sally says us ladies of the night prefer
the term sex worker i know because i am
one and have been a huge fan for over a
year oh well there you
go um we should definitely talk about
that in the members only section if you
guys are interested in the conversation
sure and there's some other stuff we'll
talk about too so if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel and go to timcast.com so you can
watch the members only section where um
we can debate
sex work and culture and uh the rat
utopia experiment things like that and
uh we've got some other stories we'll
bring up for you so you don't want to
miss this one you can follow me at tim
cast on basically every platform i have
another youtube channel
you can check that out and you can
follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere just search for it
you want to shout anything out daniel no
daniel turner
powerthefuturepridethefuture.com
uh it's great to be here and it's always
good to talk to you find fellas and sour
patch lids beating
cabbage patch kids cabbage patches
thank you very close fun time
yeah uh chris carr 17 on twitter uh
awesome
it's incredible lydia very happy for you
thank you uh check out our awesome
journalism at timcast.com we got a great
team of doing awesome work uh you can
hit me up with ian crossland really
anywhere check this out tim tim built
these uh he's like you wanna see the
best paper airplane and he wasn't lying
this is really good he actually built a
bunch more origami things over there so
i'm gonna throw this to tim and then
lydia see if you can change the camera
so you get him catching up okay
oh
yeah beautiful beautiful that's a great
paper airplane yeah it really is well
built i mean i want to see how it's a
thing of beauty oh yeah
while we were waiting before the show
started i made a bunch of origami he
likes to order i made it i made a pen
holder look at this this is you know
what you should do should nft this
official
pen holder no we should actually ship
this to someone i'll autograph this this
official pen holder for your desk
because you know you need to hold your
pen because it rolls around but more
importantly it's like tying a string to
your finger you know you pick up your
pen right and you use it but then you
put it down somewhere and you forget
where it went
with the official tim cast pen holder
you just always put your pen right back
in the holder and you put your pen
holder down and you'll never lose a pen
could you use a pencil in there as well
no okay you need this section
yeah you'll have to buy our second piece
made of 100 grade a american paper
not confident that it's actually made of
american paper but no it's paper uh yes
and uh lydia already yes yes me as well
yes i'm sour patch uh lids here in the
corner and two made me this box that i
used to put my lip gloss in he's very
handy with the paper and i do have to
say thank you all very much because
apparently all of you guys follow me on
twitter which is cool for my silly hot
takes i really don't tweet about
politics i try to mix it up and kind of
make it life less unbearable so thank
you guys for following me i'm just
loving people in the chat like give me
the pen holder
you're on to something all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you